[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
back to
give it up for your champion
is this not some good ass tekken ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the hype finally
gives way to the action here at the
tekken online challenge 2021
japan online masters watch spice and the
iconic mark man giving you the
commentary action and i just have to say
70 plus proving challengers today mark
mann how are you feeling we're about to
head into the top 12 i believe
i'm feeling very very good you know we
were looking at some of the brackets
earlier some of those no names that
we've seen out of japan and some
surprises as well and i think you know
just highlighting you know this is this
is the region this is the nation that
won the tekken uh world tour most
recently right so these guys have a lot
to show for themselves uh i feel like
the the changing of the guard with some
of the newer players especially some of
the younger players they're really
starting to show their skill and and
their consistency in these online
tournaments and i can't wait to see how
it's going to play out but man potch is
nice to do commentary with you i feel
like it's been forever it's been forever
yeah
it has been i'm glad that we have the
gifts of tekken to share this day with
and also you know what amazing matches
to look for because you mentioned
changing of the guard right i think a
lot of players are looking again now as
the number one in japan and he's really
making a splash and you know he's been
entering dojo events weeklies and also
in the online challenge he's actually
sitting pretty at number one so aside
from denmark man is there any other
player you're looking forward to seeing
today
you know we were seeing some of the
matches earlier um just you know from
the the stream that's going on from the
japan side and you know show is doing
really well unfortunately he lost but ow
you know a legend al's been playing
since he was very young as well similar
to kind of like what would uh again but
al is is again i feel like since he's
won topanga league two for tekken 7.
he's been really on a tear kind of
really figuring out his his place in the
game you know he kind of went away from
using elisa started using leroy a bit
started using [ __ ] mom as well and
you know just uh playing the good
characters he's been doing so well so i
can't wait to see how he does in the
rest of the tournament as well
yeah and interestingly enough um did
bring out the leroy against show if you
guys saw in the japan stream but he
really won it with kuni mitsu and that's
uh that's a character that we might
actually be seeing from out because he
will be on the winner's semis against
nobi a name we all know a name we all
fear a name we all love seeing uh play
but another one i actually want to talk
about is um
well uh double will be going up against
again and double actually has been
making a name for himself he did make
the switch he does have a lydia now he
does have the falcom rom
like mark man let me get your thoughts
how do you feel about the lydia's the
focus coming in do you think we're gonna
see a lot of that today
i well i love seeing it i love seeing
character variety you know long been
told japanese players have always been
you know
very
very focused on you know their specialty
characters there's been specialists like
for the longest time and i feel like
over the past few years that's kind of
changed you know a lot of the players
have been switching and delving into
more and more characters kind of really
having a solution or a character
solution for each situation or even for
each match-up against certain players so
we're starting to see that more and you
know the the reigning world champion
from the last second world tour is
actually in the losers back we have
chicorin who got knocked into the loser
side by uh yamasa's you which is a big
surprise to me but you know those guys i
believe are running into each other i
don't know who won out of that uh losers
bracket match but it's gonna be exciting
to see who comes out on top
yeah i like actually i i double down on
what you said there like just the
variety of characters we have been
seeing a lot of representation you do
still have some loyalists out there um
shout outs to jdcr he just won
yesterday's korea masters with uh armor
king he did not switch there still are
those loyalists out there but it's
really cool to see like the like i guess
the thought process that comes into
certain matchups and you see that
there's a certain um well i would say a
certain
uh meadow or if you would uh those top
tier characters we're never going to run
away from them and lydia has been a very
present
a mirror match in evo finals actually in
japan
oh yeah and and just seeing again a lot
of the different characters and a lot of
the different knowledge and you know
talking about what happened yesterday
for the online challenge in korea that
was such a sign me come on jdcr versus
saint what are we 2017 seeing those two
in the finals it was really nice to kind
of see that i was i was kind of secretly
hoping for a dragon versus jack match
but i i don't know if the internet would
have liked that but regardless i got to
give it up but seeing gan review and
armor king um speaking of which armor
king i feel like that character has been
a bit more in the spotlight i see him
being used maybe a bit more uh
throughout different regions but in
particular those character specialists
that have a history with arbor king are
really starting to shine one of the
players um that we were talking about
earlier is a hakaio who actually made
the switch over to arma king as well
he's a long time king specialist of
course you know it's not too weird to
see king using armor king as well and
you know probably these guys probably
use that tandem in tekken tag uh too but
to see him being used in tekken 7 it's
really nice because you know no one
really used him when he first came out
yeah and actually i think the story
coming into this masters was hakaio
right because he made huge uh
waves in the dojo events he actually won
the recent tsf cup against chicor and
mind you so his armor king i mean his
defense is so good you don't know when
he's going to go for that cobra cobra
clutch chain throws unfortunately he he
did not make it to i think that's
qualified i'm not quite sure but he's
not here and um we are seeing another
king emerge though in the in taheia he's
a very good king uh we've seen him in
other tournaments as well i don't know
if he has an armor king but he's really
known for that king so that's another um
i believe player that's something to uh
that we should look out for in this
matchup and he will be going up and
against carrey
yeah carrey who is
a weapon out of the out of west japan
out of osaka really made a name for
himself in early tekken 7 with his
kazumi style play but now switching over
using gander using a bunch of other
characters as well and i believe that
you mentioned he's one of the top ranked
gan reviews online
yes uh big shout outs to grants guys
nature lover for giving me that
information actually if we look at the
well the standings i wrote them down
here so it's again at 370 points so it's
safe to say he's he's really up there
right because the next one following is
novi at 290. so he's chasing far behind
but what's really scary is uh ow
sorry if he's saying
but yeah he's at 180 ow ow there we go
out 180 and right behind him is an aroma
with 145 obk with 125 kuzin who's still
here by the way at 85 points so uh this
is i would say like the blast zone
because it's like you want to be able to
uh take out owl and yeah he's he's just
hanging in there but he can still be
able to make it because he is coming at
the winner's semi-finals so uh again
it's it's all about the points right
they want to make it to that regional
finals and right now um yeah waiting in
the wings is again and he is the one to
look out for in this tournament
there's definitely gonna be heartbreak
out of this event you know uh this being
a 77 i believe 77 people close to 80
people that have entered there are
obviously a lot of points online it
being a master event especially so these
guys they have to get those points you
know everyone's been doing work in the
dojo uh with the dojo events but this is
the one that is really gonna help propel
a lot of these players like you know gan
didn't need those points right he's been
doing so well already he's pretty much
locked in and if he gets first place
that that those 300 points are pretty
much thrown away
right and then that makes the race
between
second through seventh even scarier
especially for the guys that are on the
bottom half like like ow as you
mentioned so i think those guys that are
kind of still in in contention it's
gonna be really exciting to see who
makes it out for the japan regional
event that's gonna be happening of
course uh early next year or later this
year early next year i don't know it's
around that time so
yeah so that's something to look forward
to today because yeah even though again
has pulled up far ahead there's still
chance for others to be able to enter
this especially um the ones that are
like in the hundred mark even at the 80
mark if they're able to get those points
and i think that's the beauty of the
tech online challenge it really you know
it's a showcase of each region it's a
showcase of the talent and the hard work
that they put off and that they put on
the line especially again like a player
that you know what he's still very
hungry attending you know a weekly event
attending dojo events just honing his
craft and not just sticking with one
character he's he's actually trying to
win with every character he has he won
with the lydia he brought out a [ __ ]
rom and i think he's even trying to
experiment with like a negan like he has
a lot of characters under his belt
yeah i was just watching the recent icfc
he was using leroy as well and you know
he's one of those players you know he he
started at such a young age learning
from all of the different top players
from his region uh i believe he's from
west japan over near kyushu and then uh
i don't know where he's at now in japan
he's obviously playing with a lot of the
different players in tokyo more often
than not i think everyone pretty much
moved to the kind of like the tokyo area
but he he's been on fire you know uh he
took a break for a while to kind of
focus on school and then he shifted back
getting that license uh he wasn't from
the first class of pro license uh
gamers for tekken
within the japanese scene he was he was
there a little bit later but seeing him
and his kind of rise to power over the
past few years it's been uh it's been
nice to see it's been nice to see
because you could see slowly but surely
he started experimenting he was using
leo still he was using a bit of some of
his old
keen right and then out of nowhere he
starts picking the top tier start
picking the better characters and really
rounded them out overall is such a
powerhouse in these tournaments
and i think uh i think majin brought it
up in one stream he was saying like i
think the conversation that we're going
to have now when the world is a better
place you want to see him compete with
other regions as well i mean you know
there are some online events against i
want to see again versus like arslan ash
i want to see again like face like the
different talents across the world
wouldn't that be great that's something
i look forward to constantly and i think
him as well that's why he's constantly
sharpening his sword he's he's getting
ready for that day that he he's going to
be traveling and he's going to be
representing the japan region
yeah i'd love to see it you know
unfortunately the evo showcase again
ended up winning evo online and that
event is not happening anymore they got
cancelled due to just you know travel
restrictions and just not being able to
get all the players there but it would
have been awesome to see him go up
against some of the best players in the
world and i'm confident in the future
we're going to see that one day
hopefully the world gets in a better
place or we can see these offline events
again but you know tekken 7 story is not
done yet man we have unfinished business
for sure our anime is seeing a crazy
time jump we are we are we are in for a
treat someone's going to come back like
we can all buff with like three
different levels of skill it's gonna be
crazy
it's gonna be crazy yeah and and
yeah you gotta look at like events like
this events like different dojos where
people are just constantly sharpening
their their their strengths and their
tools because once offline kicks in man
these guys are going to be beasts and
and the japan region has been constantly
like racking out dojo events they've
been so active in the online scene it
just warms your heart and it kind of
inspires a lot of aspiring players that
this is still the gold standard to look
forward to when when it comes to tekken
so we're just waiting again ladies and
gentlemen on the the matchup we're about
to witness it's still going to be the i
believe that top 12. we're just getting
ready for that but is there a specific
match up here mark man that you're
looking forward to looking at uh
watching
um particular matchups you know i'm i'm
looking at any of the matchups that
gen's going to be playing because i'm
very interested to see the type of
characters he uses with certain players
um seeing dumble in the mix of course
you know double started using focus
started using lydia as well also in that
same regard i want to see which
characters he uses i think those guys
are on a collision course because
they're both on the winner side still so
that should be interesting of course old
favorites like nobi you know nobody's
still wrecking shop with uh you know
draganov but he's also still using steve
fox here and there so uh again i just
want to see who these players are using
and how they play out as a king fan i'd
like to see taehyung because
and how he's gonna do uh it's just a
shame that you know this is not offline
because he's one of the most emotionally
charged and fun to watch animated there
is yes
he pops off and so i would i'm only
gonna imagine like how fun it is uh and
how fun his matches are gonna be but
again with with these players and you
know the players from japan um really
stepping it up over the past few years
especially with the tekken world tour
back in uh 2019 uh i think we're in good
hands for what we're going to be
watching for the next few hours
yeah and also to give a little more
context with nobi in a recent dojo event
he did bring out the fang so that's
another character that has been seeing a
a resurgence as of late with a 4.20
update so i'm excited to see nobi's
style with that thing i'm actually i'm
really looking forward to seeing a show
versus case skate because you guys don't
know ksca is one of the strongest kazias
in japan shout out to tishman for giving
us that information and sho you know
he's been wrecking shop with elisa you
know everyone has been sort of shifting
towards to kazumi all the alisa players
have been going but show still very true
still very loyal i mean alisa versus
kazia that's going to be a pretty
interesting match and it's also if we're
going to build up this match it's a it's
a it's a matchup of loyalists you got a
casio loyalist versus elisa and i think
that's gonna be fireworks
yeah very very much looking forward to
that and again uh it's always fun for me
to see mashimas in in high level being
played it's always a treat and i think
uh
i think uh kazuya especially he can get
away with some crazy stuff and you know
we've seen some of that from uh casey at
icfc um i'm surprised that the lack of
maybe devil jin being played here you
know there's obviously a lot of devil
players um in in asia you know in japan
in particular but none of them seem to
have qualified towards the top but maybe
we'll be surprised who knows
mm-hmm yeah
has been using double gin here and there
as well
uh kuzin has been using some devil gin
here and there aside from his oscar
aside from steve but yeah as you
mentioned yeah i think i'm i'm excited
to see okazio i'm excited to watch it
but i'm never excited to face a kazuya
and and and uh kck is definitely one of
the quasis that's very entertaining very
fundamental but you know he can turn on
that cause that mishima gene where he
just goes he'll he'll just make you
guess in the corner just put you under
that block yeah yeah it's like it's one
of those things
it's one of those things where you're
like there's no way he's gonna help
sleep for the fifth time in a row
there's no way he's gonna do it and then
he goes away and then as soon as you
duck as soon as you duck the block he
does the wave dash crouch while standing
too and you're done uh it's it's music
sometimes it's music
it's me yeah at someone's expense and
it's it's been really fun to watch i'm
so excited to be sharing those moments
with you if uh let's let's hope show
will be ready for that mix-up or maybe
not even a mix-up he's just gonna keep
going low on him um we're gonna find
that out in just a bit but again you
mentioned tahiyo being the i would say
the soul king here um he's very um he's
very much uh one to watch i think he's
also been making some splashes in dojo
events but he still has to get that one
huge win and who knows today as you
mentioned there could be some upsets uh
that could be one he could actually make
it pretty far
indeed indeed if you guys are tuning in
thanks for the patience we are getting
ready here for the tekken online
challenge uh in japan and uh we're about
to get into our matches
here we go first match of the day i'm
not sure what they're giving us but if
you guys want to follow at home you can
type exclamation point bracket and it'll
give you guys an idea of where we are in
the tournament and how it's flowing
right now the matchup that you see on
the screen is going to be casual the
kazoo player we were just talking about
and he's going up against the legend
show the lisa player probably one of the
lona lisa players in japan still the
loyalists
and we're in open stage it was picked on
random of course as the first match
usually is
let's see how this plays out any
thoughts in this particular match i know
you've been watching a lot but show
actually started entering some of these
online tournaments as well yeah he's
been making a splash in icfc as of late
casey not as much but
i think the stage heavily benefits show
so at least he could you he can run away
run away from the hell sweep mix-ups and
just keep him at bay but so far it's
just being very concerned both of them
being very conservative just touching
each other up just a little bit no big
swings as of yet but i'm just watching
those legs oh my god the low fairy
oh yeah and movement and control is the
name of the game here the way that show
plays is he utilizes that movement to
kind of restrict his opponent from
getting an advantage if he has the life
lead he's going to start picking his
shots and playing very smart playing
very safe right now he's working to get
back into the back into contention right
now oh he got the big counter hit so
we'll see how is he going to close this
down oh my god another low parry and
casey looking to kill he goes for the
rage art might not be enough but one
more mix-up could do it let's see what
he does
never mind it was a boom
lasers beats robots blazers beat
chainsaws so case cage is showing us
yeah that's that's the the quick math
that you have to do now so far yeah very
conservative you don't you don't see
that much you know what craziness coming
out of k-skate as of yet they trade no
show trying to get back in this match
hits the shoe shine tagging the legs
follow up let's see what he does
good block oh my gosh great read there
from show and it's always scary because
it's those situations that you get put
into where kazooie can you know start
the blender it's like you start blocking
things and usually they go for a punch
but hey sometimes he wants to go for a
low sometimes he wants to do the health
sweep just to get the knock down it's
crazy
it's really changing levels changing the
game plan changing the rhythm just so
they can just find those openings so far
so good on both sides it's pretty evenly
matched just those micro steps just to
get away nice tsunami punish there and
show not pulling the trigger too much
nice back three just to create that
space and now show does have that life
lead but not for long
oh yeah that was a huge block great
punish here and because of the open
stage not going to do as much damage we
all know kazuya is a beast when it comes
to wall carry and wall combos
here we go oh and there's a nice healthy
kick looking to close it out what's he
going to do
yes there we go yeah
at the midst of all this danger yeah i'm
just going to jab you out of it
for the mid hey don't forget man wow
kazuya has experience in anti-air he was
a street fighter across tekken man
he knows
he was the first to ever cross right
there we go
yep
[Music]
yeah i would say very fundamental he
wasn't really going for anything too
risky and slowly just picking him apart
so what's gonna happen here my question
is is show gonna opt for maybe an open
stage you know this is something that we
traditionally see from korean players is
if they feel like maybe they got
outplayed they want to probably kind of
reset the situation and go to an area
where they can utilize movement this is
something that we see with like a lisa
players athena players eddie players you
know characters that have superior back
dash and superior superior movement in
certain situations will this happen or
is he going to go for walls because i
feel like walls may be a double-edged
sword here because you know he's going
to go into the mix but he also has to
deal with the kazuya wall game he has to
deal with the casio wall damage as well
100
um when it comes to this is putting in a
tough spot because i actually i thought
that the advantage was for show in an
infinite stage so he can double down on
that but you saw how casey didn't mind
him just going away he knew when he came
in kept him out and he knew how to like
call out those big lows so it's it's
really a matter of uh i guess like what
did what does he want to go on like you
said double edged sword if he goes for
those walled stages and you're gonna
allow kazooie to corner you and put you
in that blender so we're about to find
out now what he decides on going to the
devil's pit
you do not want to go into the devil's
pit on purpose this is kazuya's this is
like his stage
you know it's not good any time he
fights someone in this stage he kills
him it's not good how many times have we
seen him drop hey in the stage it's too
many times mark man and now you're
bringing him giving that home court
advantage
he does opt for this because he does
like towards the match point that it'll
be a free-flowing stage so show has to
capitalize but now we see the hell
switch coming out mark man
oh man the nut is about to crack here we
go the wall damage as well
very scary situation to be in especially
with that life deficit and k skin with a
nice black one too able to close out
that person i gotta say i really love
this kazuya outfit this just japanese
biker outfit this bosuzoku outfit it's
one of the best outfits in the game in
my opinion underrated oh for sure oh
yeah and case kids really don's itself
and look at that sequence there casey
again you're showing his dominance now
he goes for the ballerina spin show
still in this trying to shake off the
cobwebs from that first round but you
see that case he can turn up those hell
sweeps when he chooses to so sho has to
be very careful with kazuya's approach
okay
blocks the approach now show
still in the life deficit trying to open
him up but casey's defense is definitely
showing he's just chilling
oh what a great step he has scouted this
matchup out and look how well he's doing
two rounds straight here in this second
matchup you think like he's like he's
he's about to three stalk him this guy
is a smash brothers character he's about
to
i'll let you take over i'm gonna lose my
breath
yeah we're we're talking about street
fighter cross second but yeah this he
knows how to three stalk you now he's
gonna go for the hell sweep he's
continuing it what's he gonna do joe's
for that mid now show in deep waters
here how he's gonna dig himself out of
this trouble casey now knows when to
chill out the low parry again how does
he know
what he missed secret to your proudest
still
he messed up the combo but he still
finished in the most gangsta way
possible that was so sick
that's casey this is his stage this is
home court advantage no walls i'm gonna
move away and he's gonna follow that up
case gay three round straight mark man
that was impressive and you know key
moments that we saw in that particular
matchup is he knew exactly when a side
step in certain situations you know
elisa would normally go for like a
certain frame trap here like there's no
way he can interrupt this but casey was
like yeah i can't interrupt it but i can
sidestep it and he definitely did was
able to capitalize that that quick ender
there with that down forward one two it
was beautiful it was beauty and i love
seeing that and he obviously knew the
character matchup he knew maybe the the
player matchup maybe a bit too in depth
and unfortunately for sure he's now out
yeah yeah but who's uh sorry uh casey is
moving on in in in spectacular fashion i
mean this is elisa like having one of
the best sites that the movement side
steps and he just showed that yeah i
know when to i know how to outside step
you i know when your where openings are
i don't i couldn't count how many low
pairs he's landed by that that's just
mental damage that just knows that i
know what you're going for and here's
here's a punish for your troubles and he
will be moving on
oh yeah he's super strong and then in
between not just the the movement itself
the low pairs is kind of as you
mentioned mentioned it's like he was
going for maybe the option select kind
of fuzzy guarding going for the low
parry but if the low pair didn't come
out he would automatically transition to
a side step or a sidewalk and it really
paid off in the matchup it's like he
knew elisa to a t and of course you know
he's going to be moving on but man case
get excited to see who's going to be
going up against next you guys want to
follow at home exclamation point bracket
in the twitch chat it'll let you guys
know where we're at and how things are
going as we get from the top 12 into the
eventual top eight clutch man i don't
know if this changes your opinion but
after seeing that performance from casey
he's becoming one of my favorites to go
through very far into the tournament
oh yeah he's always been one of mine as
well but if you're talking about gan
double nobi um he's gonna have a really
tough climb because this is the loser
side the the names i just mentioned were
at the winners but leave it to ksk to be
the one to be able to adjust his plan
accordingly i mean he's he's very
well-rounded that it just showed there
he did he knew how to play uh the the
different levels of kazuya's game and i
think that's something that could take
him really far he is at the loser side
so he does have a little more pressure
coming into his next match because it's
it's do or die for him
oh yeah and just going over some of the
names in the losers bracket still we
have kuzin who uses oscar sometimes
double jin uh we have watanabe who's a
player that we're not even familiar with
but he ended up going getting really far
in the tournament beating so many known
players uh tai hayo is going to be going
up against kade and then we have bots
the war on superstar going up against
chicory who's actually made it out and
got his revenge over you in the loser
side of his pool wow
that's gonna be a good one to watch yeah
chicorin coming into this had some
momentum uh just participating in the
recent tsf event and for him to be able
to vindicate that that uh loss to you is
definitely something that he'll take in
with some momentum and that motivation
against bats that's going to be a good
one but we're heading to our next match
markham and i can't wait if we're going
to still stay on the loser's side or
we're going to see some winter semis but
by the looks of it this is what
well yeah watanabe or
gippomon versus kuzen or kujinshi
oh yeah i'm excited to see this so going
into this matchup so this is very rare
we rarely see eliza out of japanese
players so this we got our horns locked
this is a horny match the two characters
with horns are going into it and they're
gonna be battling it out who is gonna
come out on top so we got kuzen going up
against watanabe
nice wall carry to start it off oh the
back to one missed
oh unfortunate there but he did collect
a huge reward in the life uh advantage
here but now we see yeah she is a 2d
character and watanabe wanting to keep
double jin in the corner here
and mind you what tanabe also has some
known victories over g to og and a big
dojo event so he's definitely not one
eliza to look past now gets the ex flat
i mean you don't get tekken god omega on
accident oh is that too low is that too
low it's not low enough
scooped him real low there great call by
kujinshi getting the first round round
two
he hit him with the smoke machines and
laser rays great rage art to start off
the first round
oh and yeah that that's definitely a
signature of double gin now watanabe
trying to vindicate that first round
nice wraith kick followed up with that
steel pedal pushing and bullying to the
corner
nobody gets himself out of it
kind of sidestep to move away from those
dark waves
and he caught him and that was a great
hesitation there he went for the first
hit of the laser cannon and caught him
with the electric goddess as he tried to
move
oh tried to go for that low but no
wraith kick picked him up again full
blood meter on what tanabe side can he
make this comeback happen the clock is
burning down to the 20-second mark who's
in watching his toes backing away he
just needs to land one hit mark manny go
down four round three and kuzen is just
so
calm and collected as the way he's
approaching it's crazy too because the
way that watanabe is playing eliza is
very kind of unconventional very very
aggressive using a lot of interesting
pokes and setups the way he's trying to
play okay here we go goes for the wall
standing attack the follow there that is
guaranteed when you have meter
should be able to get the wall what does
he do with it though is it the low mid
mix-up what's he gonna do
nice thing for that man he's getting
he does have a meter to work with how is
he going to burn it he is in the life
lead cousin kind of chilling out trying
to assess the situation but as you
mentioned mark man just all the flurry
of offense finding the openings of kuzin
now he's gonna find this other wall
oh he tried to jump over and again the
way that kuzn's been reacting and
getting off the ground is just so good
because it doesn't put him in a
situation where he has to deal with the
mix-up however did not break the throw
there and finally watanabe on the board
he hasn't really been using the meter
unless he has a guaranteed situation
true very conservative and he's only
using it when it matters and you know
starting this round with that with two
blood meters is great and now spends it
just to maximize some damage here goes
for the low and dp follows it up is he
gonna end it on a perfect one more would
do it seven golden letters
bro this guy is crazy
you know it's yeah locked on horn versus
horn match now we see that he has no
meter to work with how he's going to
build it up this is where kuzin can
really capitalize on but after two
rounds straight can he still do it
all right here's the wall he goes for
the laser cannon the follow-up here with
the demon paw
wow he crushed the hell sweep now we see
that uh watanabe oh gets the bloody claw
follows it up they switch sides he tries
to jump in on him kuzen now will he
grant him some rage he needs to kill and
kill quick watanabe has a meter to work
with goes for the mid tries to go for
the low but the rising two from kujinshi
great stuff you know the patience there
getting that big block in the punish at
the very end it was enough to seal the
deal but you got to give it up i mean
you have to be confident in your offense
to be able to go for the type of offense
that watanabe did that eliza pressure
was no joke
as you mentioned he was throwing
everything just getting those really
fancy setups not spending the meter but
he was trying to go for those fancy
setups and um yeah it was working he got
two rounds straight he was he was
chipping away at the defense of kuzin
and he took some system to some success
but once the once the last final round
hit um he didn't have that much meter to
work with uh to maximize some stuff but
uh kuzin was able to you know exact his
revenge he got one uh one on the board
for him
one on the board but that's only the
first one you know there's still another
match you have to win and the way we
mean you know i hate to jinx it but the
way we see tournaments sometimes you
have a good match it goes to the very
end final final round i'm not gonna say
that's gonna happen but it seems to
happen a lot with this game man we just
get into the hype so much and it just
keeps going and you know both of these
players really really strong it could
have gone either way it just came down
to that clutch moment with that block at
the very end
oh yeah i think the next match if it's
any indication if we're just going to
follow the the trend of what we just saw
yeah this is going to go down to the
wire so let's see how watanabe will kind
of adjust accordingly to this probably
going to go for a different stage still
sticking with that elisa based on uh
well researcher aka me stalking him he
did send a lisa specialist so
probably uh change things up in terms of
the stage
oh
this is a one of those stages where you
choose violence howard estate yes
and i like violence and you gotta play
yeah you got to pay for property damage
to mr howard here uh i i'm i'm pretty
sure watanabe wants to break some of
these walls and just make it a quick
round for him but you know cousin not
out of the woods yet had a pretty tight
first match let's see if he can still
run with that momentum
here we go
right into it
let's see what kind of adjustments we're
going to see here maybe
there's going to be a different approach
already going for double mids where the
moon glide mix up
oh bad you don't want to be in that
position this could hurt oh you went for
the wall bounce
wow okay and punish them accordingly
going for those dps okay
no meter to burn there and we see that
yeah kuzin wanting to push against the
wall here
still breakable but look at that dive
kick excellent found its mark dropped it
a little bit but now we see the electric
finds its mark breaks that wall and gets
the first round
great opening round there i mean it
could have gone either way one of the
things i've noticed is there's a lot of
side stepping going on on the part of
watanabe he's been getting clipped a lot
by that laser cannon
oh he missed the back no
he did yeah he landed that hell suit but
couldn't get that back too now we see
that kuzin oh eats that counter hit and
now we see that uh two blood meters are
already ready for what tanabe to use
they dive kick against the wall uses it
for the splat
now bounces and re-walls him and now we
see him he gains the first uh round in
this match
watanabe is still in this oh spends it
goes low this time on that moo glide
mixup spends that wall tries to push for
another one this is the violence you're
talking about mark man gets the other
one can he push it by the balcony oh my
god there's gonna be a highlight
i know just just the fact we rarely get
to see the flowers and the garden
downstairs so let's go
yeah
i'm not eating that balcony okay max
range on that hell sweep oh gets the
launch
yeah counter hit down 4-2 able to
capitalize and get the big combo
afterwards look at this one more round
he can do it will he take out watanabe
this is you know losers bracket so
whoever loses here is out
oh here we go
on the ex mix uh the moon glide now goes
for the choke slam from hell
pushing him towards that wall he does
not want to do anything with that
balcony
he screwed up the punish this is not
good he did
as you mentioned this the steps oh my
god the hell sweep lands
who's going to make this one count
broken plate no way for the rage arc oh
that was blocked and punished cousin
two around two matches straight
yeah very convincing there towards and
it showed the patience really paid off
and unfortunately for watanabe he is out
of the tournament but man he he really
has a nice offensive eliza and it was
cool to see but again devilgen was just
too much won the horn battle
exactly
locked horns it was devilgen that came
out on top and we were mentioning right
we got a devil actually if they move on
he's actually it's going to be kuzin
hopefully he'll bring out the devil too
facing case cases that's going to happen
oh my goodness
that's going to be one for the boat
looking forward to that
yeah again
because that's loser's bracket it's
gonna be an elimination match that's
gonna be coming up um the other two
matches that we might be seeing on
stream is gonna be tajio versus kade so
it could be uh two forms of wrestling
maybe coming together the battle sumo
wrestling versus uh western style
wrestling and then we have bots and
chicarin which should be another
interesting match i haven't seen bots
playing tournament in a long time so
looking forward to seeing how his warang
has developed
shout outs to the bots because i think
he was also streaming his run and he
actually ran into uh some some stiff
competition i think he he ran into um
uh jigoku akasia and also he sent down
bikun and uh he's been going through
with this warang very um very dominant i
would say so this is going to be a huge
test for him going up against chicorin
because that's a i mean that was 2019's
uh twt winner and we all know him we all
love him i don't know which character
he's gonna be using he's been rocking
the geese as of late but he has the he
has the top he's got the the the
download the the new characters he's got
the lydia he's got the the i believe he
yeah he also has the bakum rom oh no
leroy
i feel like uh at this point a lot of
these top players all have a leroy or a
pokemon or lydia and uh that's and you
know when we were talking about choosing
violence and that's the kind of violence
i i was mentioning
but it's cool to see because we still
see a lot of again character specialists
out of here and and when you see that
battle when it comes to like you know
someone that has kind of learned their
matchups and learned the the player
matchups versus somebody that is
reaching for power it's it's a cool
battle to see that struggle and then
sometimes these guys have to switch
characters in between like oh man i
should go back to my old my old squeeze
who knows
and sometimes when they go back to the
old main it's like a baby face turn or
something or if like they go they grab
that ring of power they go it's a heel
turner it's like uh they want that ring
of power to to go with so that's
actually the
what we like to see in these high level
matches so yep as uh markman mentioned
we have taheo versus kare next and uh
bats versus chicken whatever what order
so um between these two matches i'll be
honest with you mark man i'm i'm a
wrestling guy i'm excited to see some
taheo versus carrie i want to see
pro wrestling versus sumo wrestling and
that's an interesting matchup you don't
see that much king versus uh ganryu oh
well
during the weeklies yeah
we don't get to see it enough i mean we
rarely see gary i think i feel like
genre is one of those characters where a
lot of people use them but not a lot of
people use them in tournament and we are
in for a treat right now we got kate
going up against tai heo tai heo
is a very set up heavy king player and i
love seeing all the kind of crazy stuff
that he can pull together so looking
forward to this you know taiyo has had
so many
good tournament performances good
tournament runs where he's
always done very well but he's never won
one so will today be his day we're about
to find out
yeah and he's got to worry about those
lows those uh uh down ford threes the
down four twos from gonorrhoe now loving
the snazzy outfit trying to go for the
clap early on is karee but he gets
punished
oh there we go capital punishment he's
making a statement mark man el capitolo
what's he going to do how is he going to
deal with this
and you know kyrie's all business he got
the business dude equipped nice down
forward too
goes into the big combo here he should
be able to push very close to the wall
okay how is uh tajio gonna get himself
out of this one oh my god went low what
a call out from akari gets the first
fight
by sue
you have to be very careful again
dealing with that down forward too
that's really one of the scariest things
from getting here is that down forward
three it's it's not the scary thing it's
when they use it down forward too
exactly
oh yeah
that's the way i mean we saw saint
utilize that so well yesterday but karee
gets himself out of that wall situation
oh man continues the string
let's see trying to shove him to that
corner once again watch out for the df2s
you can snipe him out of you oh nice
block on it
he does have a slight life lead here
oh he caught him with the downwards
let's do out of the air how is he going
to capitalize here oh he's going to be
in trouble oh my gosh again
oh my gosh this is going to hurt
uh oh nice wake up there oh there we go
the down four two a three
so again um what's up
two rounds straight we've seen some
flashy moves coming out of taiyo he's
just got to put it together
yeah sometimes these opening matches are
all about gathering data especially
going into the matchup nice punish there
on the downford one two hit him with a
headbutt and this time the little crouch
dash into the wall standing one plus two
he's gonna go downstairs what does he
got
oh rolling robot he's gonna go oh that
was a running throw he messed up
yeah yeah i went for the the dragon
sweep then now we see he does have that
life lead nice punish there oh they
trade but in favor of tajio he is still
in this
gotta make those moments count
let's see what he does here very
important round here especially taiyo he
wants to be he doesn't want to get out
of it
let's see what he does the walls in play
oh 100 hand slap
let me see that ka taheo does have the
rage he's even gonna be able to use he
goes for the hop knee
what a clutch uh launch there finds the
wall as well okay spends uh goes for the
people's elbow alley kick oh no not much
on a live lead but look at that carry
what a sequence
he hit him with the classic that down
forward one delay for and it ended up
working out but man that uh
you you gotta as a player like if ty hey
oh he got hit by that he has to be
pissed because he's like oh my god i
wasn't patient enough
but man that's yeah anyways uh good
first match i think i think that was a
good match for both of these players
kind of getting the lay of the land
figuring out how they're going to
approach the matchup so i think match
number two is going to be even crazier i
feel like taiheil needs to take control
of the offense though that's the thing
that really
i think was lacking and you know
obviously throws throws king is all
about throws right but king has so many
other tools once your opponent starts
trying to scout out those throws when
they start stepping when they start
backdashing and i feel like it could do
very well against kyrie's playstyle
because kyrie is always pressing buttons
he's throwing out that down forward
three he's always throwing out that jab
as well on that down forward too so i
think taheio has his work cut out for
him to make those adjustments
yeah as you said this could be like the
you know just the feeling out process
the lay of the land because i think it
was just one back one that was uh
achieved by tahiyo so maybe he will be
going for that because you did see how
carrie was very button heavy and now
going to the howard estate you know what
i think tajio woke up shows violence
here we go howard estate i again
love to see it we want to rack up the
bill here the cleaning bill
uh i mean
ganyu and king they're not really known
for crazy combos on this stage but i'd
like to imagine they can do something
right i'd like to imagine they can put
the herd on so let's see it
and the fact that tajio picked this
stage he wants to do something with
these walls
no checking for those mids the lows
finds taheo
still very poke heavy is carrying mm-hmm
tai hao one of those players are those
king players that really tends to use a
lot of the moves out of his arsenal one
of the moves though that we really
haven't seen from him is the down four
two one series there's no
opportunities to try to fish out a
counter hit he doesn't keep his opponent
in check it's probably i don't know i
don't know what it is but we're not
really seeing the control out of that
move in conjunction with the jab either
that's true that's something to look out
for if he will be using that because
it's quite effective just to keep an
opponent at bay okay still so far is
karee just dominating at the the neutral
and just poking him out nothing too big
all just pokes just racking up
don't listen to me
oh no oh and he's going for the big
damage there he goes for the jab into
the ford one plus two and he has the
wall let's see what he does he's gonna
adjust
trying to back away this is a huge
deficit how is he going to deal with it
oh right underneath the back one he
sniffed that out because he's been using
a lot of the back one as the approach
but he was ready this time and he got
him with that down forward too that down
42 has a very deceptive
crush window where it can go under highs
we just saw it there in that last
sequence tahiyo in huge trouble now how
is he going to be able to bounce his way
back away from this situation carrie
just the pokes oh my god timed clap to
collect this huge combo
nice delay there look at that he is
cashing in on the damage gets the low
parry with the right read here he's
gonna have another ball
hundred hands
oh oh no drive for tajio and no more
rounds to claim three rounds straight no
round brown
for carrick harry moving on these
matches are going by pretty fast markman
dude that was a dominant performancer
from kyrie kyrie
low parried pretty much every low that
he tried to get momentum back he knew
that he was going to go for a low and
then he just kept that pressure on and
great performance there from him and his
showing his real understanding of the
character in that particular matchup
against king so good job to him
yeah and big shout outs to tai you know
he is going uh out of the tournament but
you know he had some notable wins i
forgot to mention tayo actually beat
rang chu and sent rang chu to the losers
and rancho was one of the guys i
actually had pegged to go really far and
for him to be sent by otayo is like the
real deal when it comes to king so shout
outs to him
yeah taking out a world champion that's
not no easy feat that is no easy feat
of course one of the last matchups on
the loser side as we go into our top
eight uh we have bots versus chicorin
that should be coming up i'm not sure if
we're going to see on stream but i'm
excited just in case the prospect that
we might because um looking at
chickering because chicorin he's one of
those guys that was probably one of the
earliest to start switching and start
picking like some of the stronger
characters in the game he was one of the
first ones in japan uh to use akuma one
of the first ones to really adopt uh the
the ford four gin style play but also to
use leroy and and geese to to their
potential so uh curious to see if he's
gonna go into this with lydia maybe
because i know he's been uh using a lot
of lydia at least on stream so we'll see
and you've mentioned a who's who of
killers when it comes to characters here
in tekken 7 in this season so he's got
his he's got options bots though
maybe i hope he is because you know it's
always a a crazy day when you see a
character specialist break character and
start using another character you're
like thinking in your head like
what happened especially players
it's very rare that we see huawei
players use anyone else
it's it's that's very true
i think yoshimitsu and huang are the two
ones where you see that and you're like
what happened
did they break up yeah they will die on
that
it's true they will die on that hill
they're they're that loyal and they're
that well i would say committed to this
character so yeah a breakup could have
been but no bats is still going strong
with warang while chicorin with this
geese howard
round one yeah i saw who's super huarang
in korea use heihachi yesterday and then
he ended up going back to huarang and
almost did well
anyways we're gonna go into the rebound
it was a rebound definitely a rebound
back to warren but look at this back to
the action here oh my god chicago early
dominance in the early seconds of this
round
it's such a tricky matchup here i mean
offensively you can really smother geese
and what he can do but if geese gets the
right reads and knows what you're going
to do you're going to be in for a world
of hurt
so even though he had to eat those hits
he had to move away from that wall and
he collected that first round oh no wall
for that bounce always finds the wall
though oh my god okay chicory not
feeling too happy about that first round
still trying to make that uh that
dominant round happen look at all these
yeah all these uh mids are just hitting
yeah everything is starting to hit this
is nuts
let me see him okay going to the next
round with a meter bats is in trouble
oh yeah he's gonna have to learn how to
deal with it here
that that one two from geese is so
underrated i think that second hit has
so much ability to hit and kind of track
side step as well
wow
that was crazy
that was great stuff now chicker and has
two meters to work with has also some
rage bats yeah playing it very
conservatively yeah i just didn't want
to deal with any of that
fight yeah bots doing such a great job
here two rounds to one
how is he gonna rush him down but he's
gonna have to deal with the meter sooner
or later it's right in his face we will
and chickering is waiting to explode
he is okay
with the back three two
still has one that's fine he just had to
gamble it there bats still in a bit of
the life lead but all these pokes have
been landing
and now chickering
still calm still collected but the time
is not going to be in this side if bats
keeps running away with it
oh yeah
i feel like he's going to start taking
some big risks here we're probably going
to see him go for the down four counter
hit
we're probably gonna see him go for the
more of the back dash into down four or
two
but but the way bots is playing he's not
giving chicory an opportunity to get a
counter hit opening wow he's the big one
yep and now clock is winding down to the
final seconds
now life is still in bots's side and now
again these boxes
oh my god geez has a lot watch out oh my
god wait two seconds left one and now
box gets it with the time-up oh my gosh
what a sequence harry after perry it was
a crazy scramble at the very end he got
the high uh the high reversal there and
then after that i was like what is going
on oh man it could have gone either way
but again chikran i think pulled the
trigger too late on on his offensive
rush at the very end
that was great
that was and you know what uh we did say
that yeah chicarin is one of the known
killers out there bats being the whoring
loyalists he's still got a big task
ahead because this is still chicken he's
still very scary and he's not out of the
woods i i would say that that much even
though he did win in that really crazy
sequence i think chicago especially i
mean you saw we saw in the brackets he
lost to you and then he bounced back
even and he clapped back even harder so
bats has to be ready for chickering
leveled up though
do you think we'll see a character
switch i feel like chicory is one of
those guys where he won't hesitate to
switch characters he does not have
loyalty he has loyalty to winning and
only winning so i wouldn't be surprised
if i'll switch here in this particular
matchup and you know having just the the
presence of that perry to put a stop oh
he's going to stick the geese but his
counter was to pick an open stage he
feels like he can beat him footsie wise
which is crazy because you know we've
seen easton really get any combos he
didn't get any launches into jungles at
all
that's very true i think he just wants
the freedom to yeah be able to maximize
his combos because you like with the new
with geese's updates right he he
actually does way more damage without
that wall and uh let's see if that'll
pay off because you're giving bats that
room goes for that big low
and let's see if he can uh take this
first round
oh yeah slides on him whoa
nice wake up into the jab punish
like what i'm seeing so far
but did chikurin make the right choice
here you know
box has played against some of the best
players in japan
since the game's release you know he's
been regarded as not only the best
watering players one of the best players
in japan in general he just hasn't
really had the spotlight
but a win over chicarin would definitely
put him on that map and put the
spotlight on him but you know what
chicken so far this stage has been i
would say been a factor wow jay sky's
him out of the air
no chicken still hasn't been successful
with his approach no big launch just yet
wow the float from bots collecting some
damage here oh wow okay chicken gets the
throwbots um has to be very careful has
a meter uh chicorin also has that rage
watch how he baited the tsubaki
and now collects some huge damage and
possibly the round
can't mess this one up
deadly rave
two rounds straight for chickering
it's paying off so far whatever
adjustments he made here obviously
clutching it out that last round up two
rounds here if he can get this round as
well three round street would be a
statement here
i think he's just found the timing the
rhythm of bots and he's punishing him
for it you saw that he's going for those
punch zabaki's and has been landing the
low parry second one of this match and
now it's been paying off
now it just goes for the final yep
closes that one out three rounds
straight this is where we're talking
about with chickering you may win the
first round but he's going to clap back
even harder
yeah and he built that second meter just
in time to get that final reputation man
it was clean it was clean the way he
kind of uh controlled and had the right
reads he knew when the low parry he knew
when to kind of back up just so he could
get the the whip punish it was great
stuff there from chicorin and uh that
was a completely one-sided fight and i
see people in the chat saying download
it i don't think it's a a matter of
downloading it's just a matter of him
you know being more comfortable and
controlling the pace of the match
i think it's constant adjustment now
it's it's bots's turn to adjust to the
new rhythm that chickering brings to the
table so i think i think download i mean
yeah that's one of the
the characteristics of a very high level
player but downloaded it's like for
those long sets right so bats is still
technically in this let's see how he's
gonna adjust maybe he wants to close it
off maybe he wants in a smaller stage
just so
he'll keep the fight compact and uh
that'll he'll benefit from it because we
didn't really see that much of wall
combos coming out of bots when we were
at suk
well we barely saw launches right so it
was one of those things where because of
the close confines and because of uh i
guess the awareness he was on on point
in terms of stopping the offensive flow
of chickering right anytime chicken had
an opportunity he would answer with a
counterattack or a counterpoke um can he
do this in another stage and it'd be
interesting to see what stage he picks
going into this he picks twilight
conflict wow
okay this is where the final showdown is
happening
dang very poetic i would say and you
know what chikuran being one of the
powerhouses here in this tournament if
bots is able to get a huge win the
spotlight will be on him coming into it
and i'm sure he's going to get a lot of
fans on his side so let's see if he can
he's up for the task
jab float from chicken
walls not paying off before bots so far
chickering
no ball the wall here
early seconds and gives bots rage
oh man
he got hit by the last cities you have
to be careful nice and able to crush
but man oh this is a tall order
nice
throw working with some momentum oh my
god the republican you saw that jace guy
was blocked rebuking for that punish
chickering now in the lead
nice block on the rising too we see that
bots still trying to find his mark
trying to disrupt as you mentioned mark
man the flow of offense coming from uh
chickering but chickering with a big
block low great call out there
you know introducing bots to the wall
yeah meet my friend the wall
oh man he is nuts oh my gosh he's dead
oh no he blocked it just in time right
he was able to block you yeah now he has
no meter to work with good call out here
eats the damage
it does a lot yeah it does
oh
one more to do it to the peacekeeper to
close it out let's go
bots still in this
dude he stole that round back that was
crazy
now has the momentum shifted
and
checker in though with the defense
blocking that low went for a low parry
we have not seen the left side of the
stage it's all been a chicken just
pushing towards the right
oh yeah
oh my gosh this is gonna hurt the
follow-up yeah
one more mix-up could do it
wow just swiped at him for that mid
exactly where's the money where's my
money
here we go
oh nice block low okay
scores that plasma blade and a bots
making this one count
yeah finally getting a big combo and the
follow-up here this is going to hurt he
might be dead
yes oh final final round mark man
fight
it's one of those days tournament live
sometimes yeah
oh what kind of lives are on the line
let's go to the balcony break it and
bots and he's going to get the belly
kick
wow
huge damage coming up nice stop good
call out
he is hella dead oh no
that's true dang i can't believe
mr howard had this in him
oh
what a brutal way to die
yeah i know like round after round
robbery after robbery but at the end it
was chicker and i was starting to
believe i was like bots he could do this
you know he's feeling he's feeling the
power of chat i could see everyone like
going for the horan main but this is
chicker and we're talking about this is
chicorin's geese you thought you thought
differently just when you think you had
all the answers chicken changes the
question boom reigning and defending
world champion of course he is gonna
make that happen it was brilliant if you
look at the last sequence there he had
two meters right he ended up using one
to continue some pressure then he sniped
and he got that ex air fireball and he
confirmed and got the combo with the
standing two and the rest was history
had rage and hit him with that neo-rave
ugh
oh that was uh i almost threw up it was
it was great it was great
it was great oh yeah i have my mouth
that's uh that's the excitement in my in
in my tummy but you got to get up the
checker and all it really all aligned in
his favor bots really had all the
momentum he got the wall break he got
the the follow-up after the pele kick it
was really turning up to be a bots round
and that would be a huge upset but
chicory moving on he will be facing
carrey in the losers round two so that's
going to be a good one ganryu and who
knows who chickering might change it up
but um his geese howard is in top form
today
yeah and again if you guys want to
follow along with all the action that's
happening on smashy g if you're in the
twitch chat you can type exclamation
point bracket it'll lead you towards our
top 12 bracket and where we are with all
this that's going on there's a lot of uh
good matches that are on the way and i'm
excited of course um also excited
because you know i just want to give a
shout out to our friends over at ashley
we haven't given him a shout out yet but
astro gave me of course the official
headset and mixam of the tekken online
challenge 2021. we're here for the japan
event and you know i'm wearing these
a40s and these 840s i don't know if you
guys can see it on stream but i tweeted
a photo of it we have these awesome ear
cups uh tekken online challenge you guys
can see it right there
it's good stuff limited edition and yes
yeah big shout outs to astro
don't worry it's back it's back don't
worry it's not broken guys but yeah
big shout out to astro again you guys
have make amazing uh products and all
that so and also thank you for powering
up this event the tekken online
challenge 2021 this is the japan masters
event we've only seen the loser side we
have yet to see the winner semis so
that's still a lot to look forward to
mark man you still got gen versus double
you still got nobi versus hao and you
know and also that i would i'm hoping
kojinshi would or kuzen would still pick
devil jin so we have the mishima versus
mishima matchup between him and kaysuke
that's what i'm hoping for you know we
we've actually been very lucky that most
of these second online challenge events
have had amazing representation from the
mishima bloodline amazing representation
there was like
uh going back to i think it was uh the
south america event uh we saw
sergey master he was doing some crazy
stuff in uh in the in the south asia a
lot of the players from pakistan we were
treated to amazing casual player dark
prince who's in the chat right now
really showed off some of his uh amazing
play and then um
in korea uh yesterday we saw a lot of
mishima madness going back and forth
which is something that we see often
from that region but unfortunately they
did not win the tournament and i you
know i feel like jdcr because he's he's
a a mishima main you could kind of see
his movement and the way he kind of
plays armor king it was still nice to
see he's like maybe a different style of
machine i mean i don't know if you guys
remember but like in tekken 2 armor king
used to have like thunder god fist and
he used to have uh yeah the blackfish or
the dark copper so and it was it was
just like the machine was then so i
don't know i thought that was cool i
always thought that was cool yeah and
yeah speaking about yesterday's matches
yeah jdcr i mean again saint and st
reset the bracket you know him him also
bouncing back three matches straight
that's really one to look forward to uh
or actually you guys could watch that i
think in in the youtube channel of the
tech of tekken so i hope you guys did
tune into that i think today we have yet
to you know hit the
we're just at the tip of the iceberg we
have yet to see a lot more highlights
and a lot more mashima matches but i am
looking forward to seeing uh who gen
will be picking against double it could
be a lydia versus lydia match it could
be lydia fakamram actually could be the
top tier
matches between those two nobi though i
i can't wait to see his fang if everyone
bring it out and um yeah just the
different representations as you said we
already saw like um
back in the philippines it was ak that
won it he brought up shaheen yesterday
it was uh armor king i wonder who will
be winning or which character will be
winning uh for the japan region here in
the tekken online challenge
yeah and again as we are getting ready
to start this top eight uh i gotta ask
you patch so
on the winner's side
who do you think is gonna make it to
grand finals any thoughts i'm gonna put
you on the spot
all right this is gonna be do you want
my my gut or my my brain because my
brain's telling me again
but i kind of want nobody to go like i
want nobody to make it to grand finals
but that's my gut saying but my head
says you know again has this like i
think he has everyone's number i i would
tend to agree you know he's been on fire
he's been doing probably the most
consistently well out of uh all the
players in japan so i would not be
surprised if ken makes it um going
looking at at what we have for our top
four winners side i'd like to see ow do
very very well you know just this is
what my my gut is telling me that i i
always do for another great moment him
going up against nobody nobody now have
fought against each other so many times
in so many tournaments not only in japan
but internationally as well and uh more
often than not nobody would be the one
that comes out on top but um
nobody is in the middle of one of those
those things where he's you know using
different characters he's he's finding
less strengths with his veins but al is
also doing the same kind of discovery
but he's sticking he's sticking to his
his his his violent guns his new guns
that he has and he's been doing so well
with both
that i would not be surprised if um if
al can and really surprise a lot of
people today because you remember out of
these matches on the winner's side of
the top eight you win one match you're
in winners finals you win winners finals
you are uh guaranteed top three so
uh or guaranty top two i should say so i
don't know i i'm looking forward to
seeing whatever happens out of that
explosive i mean again double nobi now
those are all world-class players
yeah they're world beaters and if you
look at it yeah ao seems to be the one
that's
in a scary spot we did mention that he
is in the eighth spot at
180 points so ladies and gentlemen we
will be talking more about the winners
matches in just a bit we will be taking
a very short break more of the tekken
online challenge 2021 japan masters when
we return
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
the tekken online challenge 2021 japan
online masters i was mixed up there a
little bit but part spice and mark man
giving you the tekken action mark man
how you feeling so far we're at the top
eight already
i'm feeling good man we were just
talking about we saw some amazing play
from a lot of the notable players here
in the japan region but we're about to
get into the nitty gritty we got our top
eight ready to go and everything's
looking good and it's sounding good and
it sounds good because our friends over
at astro gaming gotta give them a big
shout out shout outs to azure of course
the official headset and the mix app of
the tekken online challenge 2021 got to
give them lots of love for always
supporting tekken and the fighting game
community at large so much love to the
astro family but patch man looking at it
i mean just going over the winner's
bracket in my mind we kind of asked and
talked about it right before we went on
break is who do we feel like is going to
do well here and i think we've both
unanimous unanimously said that ghen is
the one to watch out for again has been
doing so well maybe even very dominating
in in online events and online
tournaments you know he won the evo
online event he's won so many online
events as well and i think he won the
last panga league event as well for for
for offline play yeah in in japan so you
know he's he's been on fire he's been
the one to beat and you know
part of this is because he kind of
stepped away from using shaheen but he's
using every other top character that's
known to everyone at the moment
yeah he's coming in with so much
momentum i think like all eyes are
really on him he's the unstoppable force
as of now and i think yeah it's safe to
say like that's the safe bet but as we
mentioned you know what owl uh the
underdog i would say among the the top
four and winners side you know we know
double he is actually trailing behind au
in in the in terms of points so he's at
205 while ao is at 180. uh and nobi he's
always a constant threat he uh it's it's
gan and nobody that are at the top two
in terms of the ranking so it's safe to
say yes again would be the safe bet but
you know you can never you can never
tell any given sunday right mark man
with with any of these uh guys we talked
about the winners side let's talk about
the loser side who do you want to be
able to get out of the loser's side into
grand finals if everyone if anyone's
going to make a big run for the grand
finals among the people in the losers
who would you want it's going to be it's
going to be the winner of cousin and
case game i mean i want to see that
battle
go into whoever makes it out there and
you know both of those guys were uh on
stream a little bit earlier today and
and uh i i think they played some very
crowd pleasing matches you know those
you guys uh are so on point with the way
that they play mishimas i'd love to see
them do well uh but you can't ignore
kyrie as well kyrie's gan ryu has been
on something fierce he played probably
the most one-sided match that we've seen
on stream so far and he's going to be
going up against chicorin who is no
slouch himself defending world champion
for the second world tour so that match
should be fun and i don't know i the
thing is i don't know which character uh
chicken would use in that particular
matchup exactly again the loser's
bracket the lucid bracket might be as as
exciting if not more exciting than than
what we have in the winter side so this
top eight i'm i'm all for it
yeah uh same with you i think i'm a
little more hyped with the potential
mishima matchup between kuzin and kesuke
um kuzin actually in the standings he is
at 11th place so if anybody can make a
big run towards the top eight it's him
uh because uh if we look at um well
chicarin he's actually um he's already
in third in the third spot so he's
pretty safe carrie not here at all i'm
not sure where in the rankings but i
only listed till the 14th spot so if
carrie wins this bringing himself up to
100 he can try to like push for at least
nine or at least 11 spots so i think out
of everyone here kuzin uh really wants
to make a run for that top eight and uh
cousin if you guys have been following
uh on like icfc or there's some online
dojos in japan he's actually been very
present he's one of the known oscars out
there he does have a steve has a devil
gin he did i think bring out a julia i
was watching some of the streams so
again it's it's that thing you were
saying markman where when it comes to
character matchups it's like now the now
i think players aren't that afraid to
just try to go for a better matchup
instead of just stick to their guns so
now we're about to witness our next
match who will it be
and it's gonna be our first match of the
top eight and it's gonna be again versus
double
and this match man they both got their
strongest sword out um it's gonna be
[ __ ] rob versus lydia and lydia has
been one of those characters that has
been discussed a lot lately as being uh
kind of like the the secret boss that
the new the new top tier right and we've
seen it results wise we've seen it
results wise but you know depending on
who you ask they all have different ways
of explaining things on on why
in particular lydia is so good
yeah i mean especially in like high
levels like everyone in japan or the top
players have this uh have lydia her
recovery is great the way you play her
uh
double actually said that he plays lydia
that how she plays law just very with
punish heavy but wow big start to the
round for again with the three plus four
finds the corner and i'll make sure look
at that damage mark man oh man and look
his wall standing one his wall splat
move that that again does that is so
quick and there's so many ways to bait
that oh my gosh look at that he's doing
so well in this opening round
nice
double looking to come back here can he
do it
did not get the delay hit on the last
one doesn't matter
oh they both went for the low jab
round two they did they bought the same
thing but it was uh again that you know
what pushed first and he did reap the
rewards got that first round so let's
see double has that comeback factor the
hopkick lands
the jabs just to push for that corner
birds and the beast not that close but
the wall is in his side double now
trying to chip away
and again you know what he's so good
with that running knee that running
three just to create that space and just
push you but double looking to get that
first round on the board for him can he
get it though
nice whip punish one of the things too
that i i think is underestimated is the
way that
her hop kick can kind of hit out of
nowhere
her hop kick is is is very far and
different from a conventional hop kick
it goes automatically into screw but the
range that you could do it at especially
from a sidestep is insane
yeah and i think he did clip again with
that hop kick and uh back to the action
here again gets that third round so
let's see how double he'll dig himself
out away from this situation
no just trying to poke his way out ff2
but wow big launch from again
oh and he's gonna get the wall here this
is gonna hurt what's the mix up at the
wall it's a bad position to be in let's
see how double is going to fight out of
here
okay
crouch jab just for just a bit of pokes
oh the red tape mark man it's happening
but oh just again putting that stop sign
in that holding the brakes
can double be able to spend this drive
one two says otherwise down the chamber
again gets the first round a good match
and you were just mentioning the the
move red tape that down back three if
it's on clean it goes into the auto
attack animation that move has a crazy
board has some crazy vortex
potential because depending on how the
opponent will react and how they'll get
up there's a lot of things that the
player can do like for example if they
react with a get up kick right or if
they roll to the side or if they get up
straight to kind of block in and guess
on the mix-up afterwards there's so many
things that lydia can do and it's i
think one of her best
uh moves for making a comeback
especially with rage the amount of
damage that it does for the unskilled
hit with rage towards the very end the
red tape is such a crazy and a scary
move and complimenting that is of course
things like the hop kick her down
forward one and even the political storm
it covers so much ground but man her um
her low as well the down back four the
tracking and homing low that move is i
think really really really really good
obviously it doesn't crush because she's
still in the standing position
afterwards but the the fact that it can
catch you
and kind of restrict your movement is
something that cannot be underestimated
yeah you just mentioned a list of why
lydia is so dangerous right and we only
saw just a glimpse of what uh lydia
could do with double we haven't seen
much of the political storms we haven't
seen that much of her
her jab and poke game the ff2 because
against defense has been showing so
let's see if uh double will be able to
you know just show
why lydia is so dangerous
oh man
he is putting the mix though on double
let's see what he does
it was really interesting there had seen
that sequence and the way he's kind of
controlling here and her running one is
man if that hits it does so much damage
because of the follow-up
oh speaking of a lot of damage
yeah it gets that jet kick and all the
needs to get the first round wow
again has been all gas no brakes so far
with this [ __ ] run
there's that running one you're talking
about and look at that damage
a little slow there on the follow up
oh there's a sidestep pop kick that is
such a killer move
the way that it's used there one for the
red tape
oh looking to close it out that should
be it
yeah great stuff from from double
sigh of relief on his side so again you
know it's still undeterred still very
determined
chipping away and you gotta when you
talk about falcom ram you gotta talk
about the range and you gotta highlight
how he could just keep you at bay with
that yeah that that jet kick his his
three oh and just can mix you up with
that hell sweep too
charge it up to the wall
the guard break pressure as well that is
so real especially by the wall because
you're gonna be looking out for certain
things right you're gonna be looking for
the standing three and whether or not he
changes the extension but as soon as you
realize it's too late you're going to
get guard dressed at the wall well uh
big counter at three plus four
and that's gonna be it i
i felt that mark man that made yeah that
three plus four
again
since this is still a best of three
we're still not a winner's finals double
needs to yeah just pull something out of
the hat here that's the punish oh no
range on that down back two
yeah that down back one that down back
two is so evasive it's a great move
especially on hit it puts her in a
negative one state against her opponent
which doesn't sound like it's the
greatest but
because of her her options that she has
it is actually really good
and and you gotta remember [ __ ]
doesn't have the best sidestep either
true
no that was a little too close or yeah
for
again to be able to try to make that
comeback so let's see if they will see
more down back twos come from double
nice punish on that nice kick by again
rising two let's go double
and she gets so much wall carry it's
crazy there's the delay hit on the last
part of the string
how is he going to deal with it back to
the wall this could be scary
oh the red tape oh with some red i bet
is it though oh he's trying to push
towards the wall again he's gonna have
to yeah put his defenses up but no
grants double some rage
final seconds here we're halfway through
the last match the last round
is so important for double to get
oh wow turns it's a triangle trick and
again moves on go for it
he ducked he he thought it was going to
be the high extension and he ducked he
saw it he went for the wall setting too
and then he got popped in the face
has like maybe a few frames of leniency
about which one he's gonna do and you
can't you can't visually confirm what
it's gonna be you have to guess
it's crazy yeah
and it all boiled down to that one
sequence right and it caught double
ducking
and yeah i went with that for that
follow up again what a beast you know
he's he's going he's yeah sitting pretty
now at winners finals double going now
to the loser's quarters
um with yeah his i would say he's one of
the strongest lydia's out there so for
genn to be able to get a victory over
double that's a that's a huge feat so
we'll be uh waiting on uh what double
we'll be up to but yeah again does move
on
all right looking at the bracket again
if you guys want to follow along at home
you guys can tap type in on the twitch
chat exclamation point bracket it'll let
you guys know what matches we have
coming up we're gonna go to the other
side of the winner's bracket for our
next matchup it should be nobi versus
owl and this again this is a match that
we've seen so many times throughout many
different tekken games so far you know
uh nobi
a veteran actually owl veteran as well
so i'm excited to see again how they go
into this because this is a new age of
tekken for these guys um it's not as
clear cuz as it used to be we used to be
able to think like oh it's going to be
dragon ball versus lisa definitely not
the case anymore uh so i'm excited to
see which characters are going to come
to play and how they're going to try to
outsmart each other especially because
it's
this is such a big match you know the
winners semi's going into this it's a
battle to get into the winner's finals
into the longer sets and play longer
sets for the rest of the tournament
whoever wins here gets that extra buffer
so that makes the the matchups in this
in this winter semis a little bit more
scary because you know people are going
to be pulling out or the opponents you
should say are going to be pulling out
all the stops they're going to try to
outsmart each other in a short amount of
time
yeah the stakes are definitely high for
these two especially knowing that um
yeah going to that winners you you want
to have a little more leeway a little
more rounds to go a little more matches
to go especially if you're going up
against again so yeah nobi and ao um we
we know nobi as yeah the dragon off he
has been bringing it out here and there
he has bring back bryn brought out the
steve as of late he has does have a fang
as well so that's the the context for
nobi with owl yeah really all about that
kuni mitsuno so i'm excited to see if
he'll be bringing that out or maybe you
know what i'm open to also seeing
different characters if ever they're
going to surprise with the lydia or
something
give us the surprise man it's early
enough
i want to get hyped man i don't want to
get hype only in grand finals let me get
hyped throughout the entire day man i'm
just saying like you know this matchup
great that we're going to see how i love
both of those players but man the losers
bracket is looking crazy the loser's
bracket is going to be
insane so
we have after this we have game versus
cousin the mashima battle right or
potential mishima battle the winner of
that match has to fight double who we
just saw and then after that it's kade
versus chicorin oh my gosh i can't wait
who's who of killers that you just
mentioned there mark man and
the winner the loser of the nobe versus
owl will have to face the winner of
carrie versus chickering so it's not an
easy feat actually this whole top eight
is super stacked and packed so it's it
seems like great matches from here on
out and you know the amazing match
between get and double but again just
proven the well i would say the trend
right where he's acting very dominant
can anyone uh take a shot at the the
king known as gain we are seeing though
this next match ow with the kuni mitsu
and nobi with his signature i would say
his calling card with his dragon off
well surprise surprise well not really a
surprise he still does use dragon off
quite regularly but
the kuni mitsubis who we saw from out
earlier he has quite the roster of
characters nowadays but uh his kuni
mitsu is definitely one of those ones
where you could feel the strength or the
the essence of strength out of him you
know you can tell when someone plays
very strong with a certain character and
kuni mitsu is definitely one of those
characters for
he just flows so well into like her back
turn mix-ups her set dashes and nice
punish there
controlling oh wow follows it up
it's the unconventional punishes and
situational stuff that he does with this
character that really surprises me
and we'll see a lot of that he's true
makes great use of the grounded hit on
the quarter circle forward too and also
certain punishes you'll see it i think
as we go through
he's just so creative
yeah nobody has been rocking this
character for so long does have we got
counter hit down two
owl is still marching against the wall
just wants to eliminate all those
options we are seeing novi though just
tack the legs
but ow still in
control i jinxed them is that enough
oh it wasn't enough oh great block into
the rage drive oh man the blender wow
crouch mix-ups yep
oh key charge set up what do we got
nobody backing away
he does not want to deal with it all
wanted to go for the counter hit like
mid oh it's that mid-hit from that kunai
knife but nobody hanging in there
oh
cancel that out
[Music]
okay how's it going familiar with this
match
i mean if he landed that set two into
the in the counter combo at the end of
that first round that would have been
crazy
yeah it would have been nice kept that
keychart for so long
no bar breaking through
yeah still very dominant here as
wow the exchange owl has some rage to
work with but no yamasa nobi
just keeping him at bay playing it very
calculated
yeah i like the way he's been playing
you know the way he's approaching the
matchup not really letting al go crazy
and al can go crazy with this character
he just has to find the right openings
oh good stuff
wow
chain it up
and break that arm
you know just dwindling the life of ow
not even able for him to breathe and
nice punish
nobody kind of a rocky first round but
he was able to pull everything together
yeah i like what i'm seeing here uh ao i
think has the challenge where he has to
kind of figure out how to break nobi and
how to really get in there because he
really didn't have an opportunity where
you know he was able to get a reaction
out of nobody nobody was always uh very
counterintuitive for the way he was
playing there weren't a lot of you know
missed opportunities you know everything
was either a block or on hit from nobi
so he didn't really get to steal the
flow back from him which is something
that his style excels in is you know you
know he's a lisa player usually he would
back dash or sidestep and create
opportunities for himself he didn't get
to do that with kuni mitsu in this
matchup so uh i wonder if he's going to
try to shift into another character
and create like you know with with leroy
and maybe with even with bakaram he has
the ability to take more of an offensive
charge and uh whether or not nobody
would be ready for that who knows but
you have one match
you have two well exactly whoever you
yeah you're you're stuck with that
character so you you have one more
chance here to kind of change things up
but i wouldn't be surprised if you stuck
takunimitsu
yeah he still has like ways to try to
get in but as you mentioned nobody
playing very stoic right he did not
falter in the offense of owl even when
he went for that key charge he was like
all right i'm just gonna chill i know
that you're trying to you're trying to
bait a counter hit out of me
um you just saw how patient he was to
just um just weather out that early
storm and nobi like towards the end of
those rounds it was able to exact his
offense so can he still do that
second hit able to land let's see what
kind of
what kind of changes we're going to see
very quickly here from owl but right now
looking a little bit more patient the
way he's approaching here forcing nobi
to go in and look at the 2-2 mix
tries to go cartwheeling on him but
nobody's still being very cautious with
his approach he knows cooney has some
range with those knives and now yeah
just blocking all the set dashes here
uh oh let's it rip oh my god nice punish
on that warp strike the whiff warp
strike now owl has no more rage to work
with but he does get the kunai throw
round two damn he clipped him there as
he was sidestepping that's crazy
okay second hit
oh he throws back the follow up here
this is going to be huge for al gets the
wall
what's the mix what's the mix
oh i think that might have been a bad
position no first position now
yeah you know forcing him to move away
nobody has rage now ow still trying to
play the range game backing away but
nobody slowly stalking his prey closing
out that distance down two lands rising
four oh rage drive already spent halfway
through the second round
okay he's now in rage let's see if he
uses the rage drive
goes to the low double hit and the while
74 follow-up able to close it out
up two rounds here trying to turn things
around and it's working out for him so
far
ow answering back here could it be three
rounds straight that would be a huge uh
well shift of momentum
you see him go for those knee spins just
going low nice punish on side
nobody trying to go for that launch now
back turn
whoa oh my god what a sequence
into the mix what's he gonna do
oh my god
he might be dead
yo
okay
nobody once again yeah
nobody's just getting started so let's
see if al can just get that one round
first to just to put one match on the
board for him
nobody doing a great job not being
deterred like knowing when to come in
backing away down two poking away then
just backing up oh gets the tackle
yo he wasn't ready for that
the follow up here good life lead here
from nobody nobody's probably gonna calm
down a little bit here not take too much
of a risk but al is gonna have to go in
nice slighty
and cooney's got those tools to just uh
close out that distance right nobody has
to be constantly on defense okay gets
the low almost in the life lead is out
okay followed it up with the climbing
shadows lows
he wants to close this one out nobody oh
my god the frost slide lands mark man
able to pull it off and look at that
we're tied up now one apiece and i feel
like the defensive approach that owl
took early on to kind of force himself
to get counter hits here and there
definitely worked out now it's on nobody
to make the adjustment here because man
that's a that's a big change of pace
here
yeah you saw how calculated out was not
really forcing anything just kind of
relaxing going for those pokes i mean
cooney can play the poke game and move
away but you also saw that when nobody
did get that life lead he was trying to
like back up a little bit and that's
when he saw the aggression come out of
owl so
nopey has a big task ahead of him you
know already made the right adjustment
two rounds straight nobody was able to
bounce back just but now um yeah
momentum is on ali's side
all right as we go into this uh the
thought here is is nobody gonna switch
characters do you think there there's an
opportunity or a chance that we'd even
entertain that you know he's been using
a lot of fenway in tournament lately as
well we'll see i mean i i feel like
fenway has been a lot of players uh
choice recently you know we saw a lot of
marduk for a while now we're seeing a
lot of fenway for more and more people
but he's gonna stick to dragon off it
looks like
okay probably just a timing thing he's
just gonna change things up change up
his approach uh so probably yeah maybe
the thing will come out later on maybe
even if steve might come out later on
but he is still sticking to dragon off
we're going to sook
so kind of a compact stage here so al
has to be careful with what ground he's
giving up when he's back dashing because
he could find himself with his back
against the wall literally
nice oh look at this offense
going for the flip over the mix
and here comes nobee
oh great stuff in all the set yeah stuff
in all the set options here
back turn
nice oh gets the grab no he wasn't ready
for that one
yeah grab and stab
oh follow it up with the flaming shadows
oh
down forward one
wow
move
oh my gosh yeah that was insane
that was that was she can do that from
like a crouching position as well so
it's it's actually really insane the
things that she could avoid with that
yes real tricky gets the warp strike now
ow making sure his lead counts here
nobody's still trying to find his
footing in this matchup
let me see that okay gets the second hit
there
nice movement from noby
not able to convert to a full combo but
big opportunity here misses the punish
oh enrage
yeah
and something for sure to highlight even
yeah nobody just really just being a
moving target for owl a lot of these
moves have been whiffing for owl so he
has to be very careful with his approach
to nobi
try to hit him with a delay while
standing one one that is safe but there
is a gap in between kind of forcing
nobody to react he got hit by it early
on but not not biting this time oh man
wow
down two to instant running too
he has the wall positioning it could
look really good here gets the wall
bounce that's going to hurt
as he called it out mark man he reaped
the rewards there down to keeping him at
bay locking him down the movement again
for the down four no be one round away
from sealing the deal and making his way
to winners finals can owl answer back
again very very important here
especially since you're on the winner's
side you do not want to go to losers at
the start of the top eight where it'll
be much longer for you to be able to get
back on top
this is your opportunity to get into the
winner's final
oh this is all going to hit
the step and then follow that up with a
running two nobe moving on it's gonna be
again versus nobi i'll go into the
loser's bracket he's still not done yet
ladies and gentlemen but let's let's
talk about that last sequence marvin
it's like nobody's just movement was
just so on point
yeah and nobody didn't really do
anything crazy it was like his classic
dragon off style and he was just able to
kind of outpace and outmaneuver and out
space against owl and unfortunately for
ao he's now gonna have to take a trip
down to the losers bracket and i think
that's gonna be tough because you know
the he's gonna be playing against carrey
or chicorin are the two players that
he's going to be playing against and
both of those players i mean we saw
earlier those guys are on fire too so
either way i think it's going to be fun
that as we kind of shift our focus into
the losers bracket now later on today
we're going to see
genn versus nobi and again the two very
strong players gonna be going at it but
um let's talk about that first matchup
that we're gonna see in losers first
who's in versus casey
that's a good one uh the question in my
mind is who kuzen will be using because
we already know casey he's gonna stick
with his guns he's gonna stick with
kazuya but kuzin has options he even has
a kazi of his own so he might actually
consider uh well he he knows the matchup
but you're playing quesque so you're
gonna have to play the player and not
the character so i guess it's the
character he chooses
um i'm hoping to see the devil jin but i
i'm not quite confident because i know
kuzin has a lot more character so it
really depends on him what about you
mark man
um like well like you said i think we
kind of hyped it up within ourselves
that i'd love to see you double jit
versus kazuya but i i won't blame the
players that they don't go with it you
know i feel like whenever i've seen
cousin play especially in online
tournaments uh i see a lot more oscar
than than than devilgen out of them so
won't be surprised either way but i'm
i'm hopeful just to see some good old
mishima battles but uh looking into that
matchup and then
the other side of the losers bracket we
have carrey who has been using ganryu
going up against chicor and who can use
a number of characters he's using leroy
he's using falconrom he's also using uh
geese which is you know the character
that he's been using i think the most
over the past few years but um those
particular matchups it's just going to
be interesting because we don't get to
see gander you uh in tournament play and
i say that off the heels of yesterday
where we saw saint getting second place
with gary so obviously we're in for a
treat this weekend it is a big boy big
boy weekend
it's been working out
yeah
the deutsche boys are definitely um like
raving and hoping that carrie will be
able to make it far chicorindo has a lot
of characters uh i i'm thinking that
he's might still stick with a geese
because he's been put in a lot of work
especially this week especially coming
out of tsf cup he did not change at all
from the geese and i think it just comes
down to uh yeah his preference but as
you mentioned also he's not he's not
afraid of changing characters if the
matchup doesn't work and we have to
admit that carrie and checker and had
possibly some of the most dominant
matches we've seen carrie you know too
owing to you chickering you know what he
did experience some trouble with bats at
the start but once he got the rhythm and
flow going into that infinite azure two
hey
it was it was a good done deal for
chicorin so i'm excited to see these two
um two players match up but as you
mentioned we are going to our first
losers match today it is going to be
kuzin going up agai against case gay and
we are seeing the steve fox
steve i'm not mad at i think the steve
pick is great you know steve naturally
has been so good against mishimas you
know the ability to kind of restrict
things they can do especially with
things like you know one two one and
back one that is the killer there back
one is the ability of the keep out for
back one to beat out not only the
electric and god fist but also to beat
out the hell sweep it really kind of
changes the perspective on the approach
and there's the back one beating out the
dashes
i i hate to call it out that way but
that be like that sometimes
yeah asking you shall receive and now
cousin
following that up that back one with a
low parry combo he's putting himself on
the highlight reel parkman man
who's in his cruising right now with
steve the way that he's kind of uh just
playing the textbook style that you want
to do against mishimas is not let them
get in get those punishers that you need
and just kind of outpace them with your
your offense oh big counter hit there
with the wall standing too he's going to
push towards the wall this is going to
hurt
yeah it's just so much damage coming off
the bat and we see case k already on the
back foot here does get the splat going
while the wall here spends the drive
we're seeing devil kazuya
can't even use it though exercise the
devil that's steve fox yeah he's not a
boxer he's a he's an exorcist
yep
and right now things have been working
out but the rain is starting to pour
here in this opening match
let's see what adjustments casey is
going to make because right now he
hasn't really found any way to get in
offensively and look he hit him with a
sidestep three one one able to land
that's a natural combo of course
let's see what he does how is he gonna
adjust here
and you know the strength
so far
we've left and sidestep left beats out
naturally beats out a lot of the
mishima's attacks the only thing that
could really be so smart it is a dash
electric the dash electric can hit but
because it's high there might not be an
opportunity for it to hit cleanly
great that's very true you see that he's
just constantly moving
and he sniped out that low
all cousin it's all coming up cousin
dang
tex textbooks wise that was such a
brilliant uh kind of game plan going
into it the the the duck left the side
step left and knowing that he can't hit
him with a high or maybe a deep dash he
went for the hell sweep there but he was
able to throw in the ducks in between
that timing to really block and
capitalize you know he only hit him with
the wall setting one too if he blocks
that health he could launch him he could
take him to the other side of the stage
and you know that as we've seen that
could be like 40 to 50 off your life bar
depending on the combo that you do but
man great game plan going into this and
case k he's put into a tough position
here what is he gonna do
that's tough because he's only he's just
using uh the mishima i think he could
just ba maybe
just play the poke game but you're going
against steve and it just seems like
who's in just found the timing round
start back one uh did not land a single
hell sweep always was ready for the
blocked low punish with a wild man it
just seems like
who's in really did his homework
yeah you know i'm gonna say there's a
way that he can win but it's it forces
the gameplay to be very very dry right
so there are certain moves that work
generally very well against steve it's
like you know doing dash of generic
downforce it's doing things like yes low
jabs at certain times and it's it's kind
of
outpacing him and out timing him
and you know steve has a lot of tools
that can really dominate the matchup we
were talking about back one and one two
one earlier on however if you force them
to whiff there are opportunities very
small windows where where kazuya can
come out on top and get the right hit
that he needs but again that's going to
be a tall order considering the the
control level that we saw from kuzan so
far so case case really has worked cut
out for him let's see what he's able to
do as we go into this rematch right now
it was uh it was three rounds straight
for kuzan so let's see what he does here
as we get into this yeah and he's
running it back in dragon's nest so he
does want these walls but yeah this is
actually what you mentioned yeah
downforce yeah he's going to keep it
kind of safe kind of dry for now until
he gets his footing in this matchup but
uh who's in though oh wow just trying to
interrupt him as he's trying to push him
towards the wall but again the movement
from cousin he just knows when casey is
coming in and look at him he's
constantly like moving constantly
staying away from that the threat blocks
the low to the wild man now he's like he
has a huge life lead now
yeah it's it's oh here we go there's the
hell suit that he wants now see once
he's gets put in the blender there's no
way for steve to really kind of
counteract other than guessing right
mm-hmm
so okay
once they start blocking the hell swoops
that's a completely different tell so he
has an opportunity still but again
sometimes collecting the data you got to
do it early on and we've talked about it
so many times the health feed is
something that you live by and you die
by
he might have to make those gambles come
out and probably not even throw caution
to the wind to throw off the rhythm and
the reads of kuzen so far so good on the
side of keisuke oh he's gonna break that
guard with that blue stuff pushing
towards the wall now with cruz and
bullying him gets him out of the hell
sweep state pushing against the wall
now just slowly just dissecting the
health and cousin five rounds straight
can he make it six fight oh man i mean i
liked what he was going for there but
right now kuzin is on fire the way that
he is approaching the matchup he's
really taking apart the games the
playstyle from that cascade is
comfortable with
oh
that was sick
normally nobody wouldn't be able to
sidestep it the way that he did but look
at that 10-count throw
mm-hmm
right
yeah still in favor of all the
yeah twin pistons launch
you know this could be the momentum
shift that we're looking for k-skate
finally puts one on the board for
himself
i'm surprised we really haven't seen use
of the wall standing one plus two from
kazuya either i know it's it's not it's
not really a move that you can just
throw out willy-nilly but i feel like on
wake up at least the way he dashes in
and tries to create opportunities it's a
move that could net him some positive
here
oh my god he's so good with that the
guard break
oh but look at that oh i wasn't able to
get more out of it and now we see that
case keep fighting with his back against
the wall he just needs one big launch
rising four follow that up with a steel
pedal final round mark man
that was a huge risk there he went with
the mid and able to able to pay off
right now casey
looking for that opportunity the big
sidestep that was huge oh
just get some jabs playing a little
conservatively and cousins gonna rack up
a huge uh life lead here
who's in is so sick
oh my gosh speaking of sick my stomach
yeah just hold that for me well we see
the case case in rage uh oh below the
belt now we're seeing him oh my god
he's hella dead yes he is hella dead wow
ksk
flipping the script here no we're not
moving on just yet we're taking a 1-1
we're going to take this all the way to
the third match it's the best of three
you know what's crazy i felt like casey
lost every single round even though he
won the match i felt like he lost every
single round but it came down to the
clutch moments at the very end whether
it was that down forward one into the
follow-up with the steel pedal or that
clutch electric when god fist
he he definitely was on the verge of
losing but he pushed it out at the very
end
yeah man what an it seemed like that
i was gonna say like leading up to this
and kind of seeing the game plan right
the game plan that kuzen brought to the
table looked like it was it was
something that was just locked and
loaded undefeatable right no way for for
casey to get in but he made it work he
made it work towards the very end and he
was able to still kind of play his style
and take those big risks and make them
count
and just to highlight what you said
right
the way he won those it really went down
to the wire so it seemed like he really
had to go through a lot just to get the
game plan going and i think that that
goes with that
i guess he turned up his play style of
conservat uh being conservative uh
conservative so like he brought it up a
little bit but you saw him take a little
more risk with those health sweeps you
saw him take a little more risk to just
go in like that so
it's gonna be quite tough and this
victory will be well earned if he's able
to get it so let's see how casey will
try to maintain this lead but you know
what kuzin can still adjust he still has
uh he's still got levels to steve
yeah
again there's i think this this matchup
can evolve a bit more you know there's a
lot of things that we really haven't
seen from cascade yet i saw him go for
the standing four counter hit once in
the matchup and he wasn't able to pull
it off but that kind of shows you that
he's looking for ways to kind of bait
things out there's a wall standing one
plus two that we haven't really seen
from him as well which has some
admirable tracking
uh and just the ability to kind of get
in and create these opportunities you
know he landed a big risk there with
that wall standing too kind of test his
opponent so let's see what he does now
using the forward four oh and this time
the election lands its mark he's gonna
get the wall as well it's gonna hurt
okay big damage coming on the early
rounds still maintaining the lead is
cascade now moving away he doesn't want
his back against the wall you see the
constant movement from both these
players who's in oh gets hit by the hell
sweep and the forward 4k
finally in the lead
fight yeah and what a way to kind of
turn things around oh he caught him on
the on the get up the bottle up here
he's gonna get the ball this is gonna
hurt again
yeah
okay nice patience there by casey not
waking up right away but look at that
the wake up three wake up low who's in
trying to go for that massage in the
wall but no
casey now realigning himself oh my god
mark man my gut
yeah great adjustment there look at the
damage
oh oh
okay is playing out of control but nice
he did it backward albatross to avoid
that final sequence that was pretty sick
except this wasn't enough
yeah i just went for that down four so
far it's all been cascade
who's in now in the back foot here gets
the low parry but he wasn't able to get
much out of it ksk still chopping away
at the legs
[Music]
is betting at all he's trying to get
that extended duck one trying to catch
him ducking but you know casey is not
going for it casey is not going to risk
it all on a duck
yeah oh okay
probably electric attempt but now we see
cousin though
finds the wall
this time he didn't get his combo there
you know looking at that first match and
the way cousin controlled it there was
no way that i would have
between matches put money down on casey
but case gay
definitely
definitely buckled down deep and he made
it happen for himself so i got to give
it up that is a brilliant sequence of
events that really led to his victory
and for him to continue his tournament
streak because right now kuzin is out of
the tournament unfortunately at seventh
place so i gotta give it up some great
play that we've seen from kuzen and good
steve of course uh good double chin that
we saw earlier as well but unfortunately
out of the tournament now and cascade
and his kazuya will be moving on
yeah and and like you said i just want
to echo the same sentiments you had at
that first round it really looked like a
done deal for cousin because he had his
number but casey just showing his
veteran experience was difficult he had
to go through adversity had to deal with
a difficult matchup but it can be done
ladies and gentlemen i think casey we
see our dark horse now casey moving on
he will be facing double so at least
list of the the mishima bloodline
running rampant here in the top eight
yeah you i feel like we've been treated
with so much great kazuya play again
throughout all the tekken online
challenge master events so it's great
stuff but guys we will be back with more
of our top eight we are gonna be taking
a short break and we'll be back right
after these words
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
the tekken action does not stop here at
the tekken online challenge 2021 japan
online masters we got geese versus
gonorrhea we got chicken versus uh karee
so let's start this off markman
you thought we were on break i'm
actually doing commentary from the
bathroom right now this is going to be
exciting
so let's find out now again
man this this astro headset is so good
it reaches all the way to my restroom
man i can't wait to see you guys is so
sick
let's see how he's able to deal with
chicory and his keys because you know
geese is one of those characters that is
so good at kind of threading the needle
with a lot of his pokes and
you know ganryu doesn't have the
quickest attacks but his ability to kind
of create space using things like down
four two from a certain range that i
think is going to be the key for him to
kind of break down the offense or the
defense of chicorin
yeah and just the conditioning right
down four three down four three then
he's gonna sneak in that down forward
too chicory now does have some rage to
work with but you know what carrie on
the gas here not allowing it oh he jumps
in on him mark man
good stuff there opening round very
important way to kind of get a feel of
uh of the match up and right now you
could tell ganryu or kadri i should say
is prepared for this east matchup
he is yeah it's it's showing so let's
see if he'll be able to take uh some of
these rounds off of chicorin chicken
still building that bar and now introdu
trying to introduce carry to that wall
always going to float him to the wall
nice big combo big life deficit early on
here
kyrie's going to have his work cut out
for him how is he going to react how is
he going to get down twos are you
serious he's pulling out all the moves
yeah
he's gonna use all the moves he paid for
the entire game he's gonna use
everything now we see the checker and
though in the life deficit trying to get
that throw going but watch out for that
back three two
oh he got clapped up though
he should be able to close it out here
good stuff
yeah it's all business with his health
and curry
this is like a business these have gone
wrong with geese yeah
he's like uh so i'll i'll meet you for
our two o'clock at the top of the
mishima building
we could squeeze in a few yeah we could
throw hands on the way up there and then
we see that uh genre you know oh my god
hundred hand slap
jicarin has two meters to work with can
he burn the meter in time oh oh gets the
splat
collecting some damage here but kyrie's
still looking pretty healthy
oh he has double double jab soon
oh my god oh the backswing blow
whoa
check her into the air fireball yeah get
that out of here
that was crazy why would you go for the
backswing vote man he do he probably
know something that i don't but man that
was crazy that was a huge risk i kind of
just threw it away
and chickering right now between all of
that just built so much meter he's close
to two meters here how is kari going to
catch up here
oh my god is kyrie going to catch up
check her in with that down through wake
up now we see that yeah chickering
collecting some huge dividends from that
wake up low
harry has to play his cards right he
can't be too reckless approaching
[Music]
backing away
yo
whoa we're going the other way there we
are
kyrie working on a comeback here chicken
just needs to land one clean hit can he
get it final seconds of this round
trying to zone him out clap little too
short oh just goes for the legs
clean stuff i like what i'm seeing here
the way that chicorin is really
approaching the matchup it's not putting
a lot of gaps in in offensively and
karee has to really really work for the
damage that he's trying to get out of
this and again that's an uphill battle i
think it's so hard to kind of penetrate
your opponent's defense with ganryu you
have to kind of rely on certain things
like you know using down forward three
at the tip and then forcing your
opponents to react and trying to
capitalize off of that you have to like
do a lot of spacing tricks to make
things happen uh to get a clean hit on
them and it's not easy it's definitely
not easy
yeah especially going comments against
chickering we did say that karee seemed
comfortable in the geese match look
early on but towards like the final
rounds of that match you just saw how
chicken was able to find you know ways
to get around the low he jumped the low
and just uh uh got the the dive kick and
we saw that he was able to just really
manage the range and and not even allow
um
uh kyrie to even get in so yeah kyrie's
gonna have to do some adjusting here on
out
absolutely and
um i'm trying to think like in my head
like what can he do in the matchup i
mean obviously anything that he goes for
like in terms of like you know
putting pressure on his opponent is
gonna probably bring more risk and you
know check her in the way he plays it's
like he's a wall
he's always been like a wall in the
style that he plays so i i feel like
again he's he's going to have his work
cut out for him i think it's going to be
one of those situations where there's
going to be a lot of trades there's
going to be certain scrambles and
whoever really clutches it out and comes
out on top that's going to get that and
take it to the the round level and
eventually the match level but right now
we're going into the twilight conflict
which is the stage of choice here for
cardi
and we seem to be selling a lot of these
bouts in twilight conflict so let's see
if this will uh pay dividends for carrey
and yes yeah get to the sumo throw throw
him down
oh my god harry he dude
he knew
he did chicken scene to the future again
stops the low option finds the opening
thankfully for kyrie didn't have a bar
to spend now he does
okay
one one two to close it out round two
chickaroon had two huge reads there he
knew when to do the parry he knew when
to do the jumping this guy has a read on
the matchup look at this while standing
wow
dude he's so good
yeah now what are you gonna do he reads
here and it's been paying off uh oh yeah
he's able to get out of that situation
let's see though chickering has been
making these huge reads and it's been
paying off so well for him carrying out
just backing away trying to create some
distance
clap gets blocked and now check her in
still trying to find his opening he's
not going for anything too crazy just
yet now has two meters jumps in again he
baited him for that too he knew at that
exact moment once he did the running one
that his opponent would try to react
with some type of blow and he got the
jumping on him so clean
nice punish
yeah okay nice df2 here carry catching a
break here and gets the balcony break
collect some huge damage
he went for chickens are still on point
he went for the big sumo bomb there but
wasn't able to get it but look he has a
huge live lady almost died right there
he almost died to that jumping
because he has two meters in range that
would have been brutal round four it
would have been so yeah carry you know
just getting that round just by just a
little bit chicory is still very much in
this match
especially with full meter now
how are you going to deal with it we
might see something brilliant here i
mean he has three meters only good only
good things could come out of three
meter combos
oh if you're using that geese but carrie
has to be very careful okay rising
punish there
catches a break here
pushes for the wall and still keeping
you know things real close quarters here
see what he does here again having to
deal with all this meter is it has to be
in your mind here that you're going to
have to change it up
oh my god he's he's going for the lead
nice
he just needs that one big jump in
though but carrie uh oh tries to jump in
on him
final seconds mark man how is carrie
gonna close this one out he's trying to
get run away with it
oh my god he almost found an opening
there final
he was able to beat him on time man that
uh that chickering guy is really good
that chicory guy is really good and you
know going into this we saw how strong
karee was especially in his prior
matchup when he played against taiheo
but chikarin on a different level from
what we've seen so far he definitely
controlled that and of course he's gonna
move on man he is he's good that boy is
good
yeah who's this chickering guy my gosh
he seems like a world beater he's a
world champion and even the way he was
able to get that time up was just insane
uh you saw how the the life lead we were
thinking kyrie was just gonna all right
we're just gonna throw it all in that
down forward three but checkering had
other plans so moving on he will be
facing out in the losers uh quarter
finals
yeah so looking at what we have for our
upcoming matches that puts things into
perspective we got double versus kesuke
we have owl uh versus chicharron
and then of course on the winner's side
we still have gan and nobi so uh the
final six players are ready to go as we
kind of figure out who's gonna be
getting fifth place and who will be
getting uh even more points with fourth
place onwards so of course lots of
tekken that will be coming up even more
so
good stuff man mm-hmm this top eight is
that like what i'm seeing
and i feel like it's a gradual increase
in hype with the matches we've been
seeing like that was definitely one for
the highlight books uh without how that
ended and i feel like from here on out
it's gonna be highlight after highlight
because of how stacked uh this well yeah
this uh these matches are gonna be these
top six so i'm excited to see from from
winner's side all the way to losers like
you cannot miss a single match ladies
and gentlemen
oh yeah
so we're close to the halfway point of
our top eight again i want to thank
everybody that has been tuning in and
watching you know all of these tekken
online challenge master events that have
been going on uh this is going to be the
final weekend for these events as we
shift over into the regional events that
will be happening uh starting in early
november so i hope you guys are ready
for that of course uh seeing a lot of
familiar faces obviously players that
have been qualifying most of the ones
that are in the top eight are probably
going to be in the regional final as
well uh but there's a lot of guys that
have been doing work at least on the
dojo side you know a lot of different
tournament organizers running events
throughout different regions around the
world and you know this year we've hit
more regions than we have in the past
when it comes to tournaments a lot of
that is is thanks to having the
organization and working with a lot of
the community communities to be able to
do this kind of stuff so again looking
forward to what we have in the future
for these regional events and then uh
hopefully we'll be able to get back to
offline events sooner or later
yeah and and you know it just shows that
you know the community is still finding
ways to just help each other grow and
also with the dojo system as you
mentioned it's constantly growing so i'm
really excited to see once everything's
opened up and how how everyone has grown
in this in this crazy time right you
know and we have things to look forward
to like the regionals we have tekken
online challenge masters 14 regions and
you know what with with what we're
witnessing now japan has always been
that gold standard and they have also
adapted to the online environment and
they have been constantly grinding i
think there's dojo events left and right
each and every week so you gotta you
know
really look at the japan scene now and
note that when offline comes in these
are the killers we have to look out for
we got to look out for cascade we got to
look out for kooz and we got to look out
for carrie all these guys that we've
been seeing today and i think this is
just a milestone in their journey once
uh we're able to like open up to offline
absolutely absolutely and you know in
the meantime we have these online events
uh that are happening and you know in
japan they actually do a lot of esports
uh activities for the game officially
you know they recently had uh as you
mentioned a lot of dojo events tischuma
our friend who actually does commentary
for icsc sometimes he ended up hosting
icfc special and running a tournament as
well and that one had a lot of people
playing some of the players that we see
in this top eight today but uh again
it's just really cool to see that we've
kind of shifted as a community from
going from these offline events and you
know being safe staying home and
shifting to these online events you know
i'm gonna be very real with you know
these online events they're not the same
as you know seeing high level play
offline but i'm glad we have something
to watch and look forward to i'm so glad
because uh you know you really get to
see
the grind and you know i i feel like
there have been some offline events that
have happened already where a lot of
these online players had newfound
confidence to go out there and perform
at events and they actually did really
really well and really put a lot of the
veterans on notice with how well they
were able to kind of perform in these
events so it's nice to see that you know
the the grind is paying off and people
are able to adjust and use that
experience that they get from their
online play to expand as a player and
grow as a player
yeah and as you mentioned like in in
these crazy times it's good to look
forward to this and it's always so good
to rob players and highlight them so
ladies and gentlemen we're about to
enter into the i believe top six but we
will be taking a very short break more
when we return with the tekken online
challenge 2021 japan masters so see in a
bit
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we're back with the
tekken online challenge 2021 japan
online masters podcast and the very
powerful markman giving you the
commentary action we're at the top six
we talked about it a little bit mark man
and we talked about like casey really
making a name for himself now and he's
been known in the japanese scene for a
long while
um
how are you liking this top six so far
you know i'm liking it you know we've
seen some great varieties some great
champions of yesterday really battling
it out for these top positions the
loser's bracket just like i thought it
would be you'd be ultra violent and
super toxic but the one that stands out
to me
is the comeback earlier that we saw
where casey went up against cousin and
we thought i mean after that first match
i thought it was all over but he was
able to mount one of the most insane
comebacks and he really turned up the
kazuya uh meter you know you know what
i'm talking about when kazuya started
doing hell sweeps and start doing back
dash electrics at the right time
he really
showcased the comeback ability of that
character and again
i gotta say i'm cheering for him you
know out of the loser back i really want
to see how he's gonna do and how he's
gonna perform he's gonna be going up
against double and you know you
mentioned it earlier that casey is out
of all the players that we have left in
the top eight
is the only one that currently isn't
like a no sponsored player
so this guy
is definitely going up against you know
the the the next level of pro gamers in
japan so i want to see him do well yeah
yeah he's the real deal and i remember
one time when tishman entered icfc and
he was you know accusing majin bringing
the brackets because once he landed his
first match was against cascade i'm
going up against the best kazuya like
come on man then he got sent to lose
right away kck is the real deal and i
hope this platform to take an online
challenge masters for japan will
showcase that because you got to put
respect in his name and you know what
just showing that he has levels to his
kazia and turning up the level the
mishima bloodline of that toxicity is
going for those health sleeps going for
the electrics really putting cousin i
mean in the match match-up wise on paper
steve was really good and for him to
face that adversity uh he's definitely
has a head of steam but he is going up
against double which when we saw it on
stream against genn you didn't really
have a chance to highlight his lydia so
i'm excited to see uh like what kind of
lydia he has he says he plays it like
his paul and even if he is going to
bring out the lady maybe he wants to
bring out falcom rum too
there's a lot of options and you know
one of the best options that we have is
partnering up with our friends over at
astro gaming you know they're again part
of the tekken online challenge they're
the official headset and mix amp of the
tekken online challenge 2021 so i gotta
give a lot of love to our friends over
at astro for always supporting tekken
and the fighting game community much
love to the astro family
mm-hmm yeah and whenever we like react
with like high-pitched screams whenever
we hear the counter hits because of
these bad boys right here they make you
hear the insane action so please if you
guys are looking for headsets or mix amp
look no further than astro because they
do support awesome events like the
tekken online challenge so
with that i mean i'm excited to see uh
the rest of these matches and uh let's
talk about a bit we got again nobi and
this has been a match we've seen well
we've seen an online dojos as of late
and this i think this is what prompted
in the icfc dojo in gen face nobi this
is what prompted nobody to go for the
the fang i believe because that's when
he showcased the the thing lately but
with gen we still haven't seen i would
say his final boss which is lydia
because lydia was the one that got him
that evil win and so many wins he just
brought out the falcom rom you think
genn's going to go with [ __ ] rum
first then lydia or just save lydia like
for grand finals or for like
a really tough match
i think it depends on the matchup you
know we've seen we've seen gan play uh a
bit on stream earlier but when he picked
focker mom it didn't seem like he had
really that much trouble going up
against double when he was playing i
feel like he
for him the match-up starts when he
picks the character and it's not how he
reacts and adjusts because the character
that he's picking he's intending to win
and win probably with the least amount
of friction in the least amount of
trouble and so far so good i feel like
whatever character he's going to use
like if if there's a need for lydia
obviously she'll he'll use her i feel
like jen is that calculated as a player
once being calculated we saw how nobody
was able to have a very calculated very
measured approach going up against al
forcing him to not really go for that
second run placed on forcing him to try
to open him up so
we'll we'll see because i think out of
the two matches it was nobi that had to
go through a little more adversity since
it was a 2-1 well again it was just
utter domination from bell to post so
that's gonna be one to really watch out
for and see because these are the
technically the top two in the standings
it's again with 370 points while
nobody's trailing behind with 290. so it
could be a big shake up and also um when
we hit that regional finals it's also
good uh for them to run into each other
now so they'll be able to develop a game
plan going to that regionals
[Music]
oh yeah
either way just looking at the the
remaining six players that we have uh
maybe the player that we haven't really
talked about as much is al out of all of
them so i was going to be going up
against chickering in the loose side of
the bracket yes and between those two
players i feel like i feel like those
two guys
that match up is the one that's going to
decide the losers back even though you
know my heart is cheering for casey as
he goes up against double i feel like
those two players are the ones to watch
out for the losers bracket whoever gets
up on that side is going to be the one
to watch out for in the grand finals
yeah 100 we saw how chicken was able to
have an amazing performance against
carrie al unfortunately you know what
did fall to nobi but he's still a big
threat we we
in top four you did say that your gut is
being ow and he could make an amazing
run but looking how how chicorin deals
with like round one matches it it could
go either way so let's see our next
match is about to be in front of us
ladies and gentlemen it is going to be
double versus case game we're seeing a
martial law is this a new character i've
never seen
double music is this a new character
that's crazy
i don't know man i'm pretty sure you got
some good ass tekken t-shirts with that
martial law hope you guys can check that
out but we see martial law versus kazuya
a legacy matchup if you would
early start for casey finds the wall
breaks the balcony now we see him just
play his dominance here
but this is doubles go-to character this
is the one he gets yeah this is his um
his go-to this is his yeah his one bay
so now we see him
push towards the wall oh he breaks it
continues the combo
oh he went for it he's a madman
you see that yeah is swinging and
swinging big oh
speaking of swinging bait he was ready
for that electric whip punch there with
that while standing too that was nuts
good stuff there double taking that
first round
yeah and back and forth they go right
casey is very much in this match finds
the electric we're seeing a lot more
aggression a lot more offense coming out
of k-skate not that
real measured approach now in the early
seconds splats against the wall once
again
oh my goodness look at all this damage
and all that from one sequence so far
let's see what cakes is able to do here
and if double is able to come back
because he does have rage there's the
first slidey
oh magic four to the wall thankfully
that mitigated the damage okay jess goes
for a hell sweep was that tip range and
now just goes for the down four back and
forth they go mark man
here we go the follow up here
let's see how he's able to really break
him down because right now oh my god he
got him going for the dragon slide
motion and he hit him with the electric
out of it well he messed the compo
this is interesting oh could have yeah
gonna punch the somersault there keeping
him at bay here now we see case k
wow what a whip punish there he gets the
third round
interesting sequence from both of the
players uh they're definitely playing
with some type of nerves here i don't
know what it was but they definitely had
a moment where they were both like i
don't know what's going on mom's
spaghetti oh here we go
i never freeze but in this high level
you will have those type of moments
ladies and gentlemen but double shaking
with the cobwebs wow ksk fighting his
way out of that wall with a hell sweep
now we're at center
nice oh he'd go for the slide i thought
he was going to go for it oh he's dead
wow
i was gonna say if there's ever a sign
there you're gonna have to switch up the
character that might have been it
because
at the very end you know even though it
comes down to how you deal with the
offense from kazuya i feel like had he
an another character whether it was
fakamram or even lydia he might have
been more well equipped to kind of deal
with that offense
true and it just shows that you know the
legacy matchup case gate was ready for
that law he was he was so good at um
just sniping out those options and just
really imploring his offense and um yeah
i think double now really has to
consider picking a different character
as much as i love the martial as much as
i love that shirt mark man i think
double considering uh changing up that
character
yeah which sucks duke is like you know
he's he's his main is is love right but
i feel like uh
sometimes the game develops in a way
where you have to you're forced to kind
of
try other characters out and you know
obviously he tried with law here and he
did okay at the start of the match but
he fell into the vortex man when when
when casey flips that switch sometimes
all you can do is watch and and that's
what we saw a lot towards the end of the
match
poetry in motion but for the one facing
kck it's to their expense
so he will have to adjust maybe yeah he
might consider the lydia or the fakamram
either way um that can put kck off a
loop going with a lydia no and we're
going to twilight conflict this seems to
be the stage of the day markman
yeah i'm actually curious to see this
because i know doubles style the way
that he's been played we haven't
necessarily seen it when he used lydia
earlier when he was facing off against
again but i've seen him play in other
matchups he makes good use of the
political storm and this might be a
specific character matchup where he can
actually utilize that it's not like he's
fighting against the big tree trunk legs
or pokemon this time around it's going
to be a more methodical approach and how
he's going to go into the matchup
followed up and finally found the wall
oh the heaven and earth low
okay now casey has rage but look at the
life he's got okay
gets the mid maybe he and now goes
the driver
you just want to maybe he wants some
mid electric that's all he wants
let's see how it goes for it and i
wasn't able to bring it out but
excellent start for double yeah
oh yeah
okay playing a little more methodical
now as you mentioned uh double might
want to be able to be the one to push
for the offense and try to open him up
you see he is chilling waiting for his
openings but wow the range on that
rising too
it's like it's like he's used to using
while standing too for some reason
it's like he's used to it oh my goodness
not sure why from a lydia maine okay
now two rounds straight yeah this this
lydia pick has been paying off so far
for double but you know what kck as
we've seen in the previous matches can
be a slow starter for matchups he's not
really comfortable with so oh my god low
parry
here we go there's going to be a lot of
damage
last hit delayed of course
how is he going to deal with this here
oh
found the wall
oh my gosh all right casey starting to
yeah build up some momentum but the red
tape just there to stop him it's the
wall splat double oh get to the low
block case gonna make this one count
great stuff there hitting that glorious
demon god fist follow-up into the combo
into the rage art finally getting around
here against doubles lydia
let's see if that momentum will help him
carry and maybe even up the rounds
he's still a tall tower oh my god
is crazy it's so crazy yeah
i can't believe that hit found his
ankles anyway yeah that's one of the
moves to go to but then there's that
political storm you were talking about
another lowberry
nice delay there
oh this is big it's the wall splat
and he's gonna go downstairs down the
balcony
oh he missed it oh off axis oh he's
putting on the blender oh my god the
rage drive from lydia and now breaks the
balcony double taking the round and the
match
pretty well what a piece
yeah lydia's uh lydia's a good character
i think a lot of people have been
talking about it recently but obviously
it works out for double in his playstyle
it gives him more tools in the matchup
as well and i think one of the things
that we saw is
i guess maybe the fear of lydia getting
up close and how casey reacts to it and
it obviously worked out in in double's
favor because you know he started
getting certain things like the while
standing one string he started getting
the wall standing fours and then we
really haven't seen him use too many of
her tools we have we haven't seen the
hop kick we saw obviously the wall
setting too during certain situations
but uh i think that that's been key so
far but
again i feel like you can't count out uh
case
because again all it takes yeah is one
health sweep and to that'll start
everything
uh a series of unfortunate events
that's true
then that sequence i mean that snowball
can turn into a landslide easily with
with how cascade managed to get himself
out of that situation with kuzen and
yeah you know he can never count him out
even though double i would say yeah he
was able to win that in sort yeah
dominant fashion but still kck was
showing showing some signs of life
showing some moments of brilliance there
and you can also make the same case for
double he did not show the full toolkit
of uh lydia not much hop kicks i think
there was like one down back to that was
hit we did see some rising twos there
but we haven't seen like how we we see
like high-level lydia's like again use
lydia just yet so still a lot for these
two players to showcase in this matchup
and it's still pretty evened up so
double versus gay only one can move on
to the losers semi-finals who will it be
and where are we going
devil's pit
oh man home field advantage and you know
he's recognized it he had good luck
early on as he played on this stage and
we're going back again let's see how
this one
plays out
devil's been a very unique stance the
only one of the only stages in the game
where where it's the potential final
round it goes into an open area
and we saw that he can deal well in open
areas but now who's going to take
advantage of these walls nice punish
from double followed up peppered it with
a little low there
no cascade being very measured with his
approach doesn't want to get caught with
anything big from lydia
that was great stuff and he's gonna get
the wall this time too
yikes big damage try to go for the side
step four but caught him with the mid
and now double yep he's all warmed up
with this lydia
all right he caught him with the wheel
kick to follow up here let's see what he
does
oh we caught him out of the air
fast thinking on casual side oh they
trade in favor of case k and just like
that not even 15 seconds was able to get
that second round
i mean it was pretty much a perfect
other than i trade
you're doing a great job of really
controlling the offense off the okazami
but going back the other way here comes
double
oh
try to pick him up
yup
good punish there
uh oh moving away and okay skate
trying to capitalize on that wall
situation but double looking pretty
healthy running one
perfect
oh that was wow
yeah so now find a potential uh uh set
point for a set round for a double
oh yeah let's see what he does
kck
needs this round to stay alive of course
get some with the big bop the follow up
with the steel pedal and the stature
kick
nice
well rising twin pistons there now
double
in the life deficit
constantly ducking he does not want to
deal with those electrics or lows oh my
god speaking of electrics that one lands
final final round markman
oh yeah here we go
could be anybody's match both of these
players have been doing very very well
but again it all comes down to this you
have to put all your cards on the table
oh and a big block
yeah kck was yeah betting it all in that
well bet the first few seconds of that
round with that low but now double
trying to still maintain the lead here
another blocked health he knew
he knew that he was gonna go for the
hell sweep after that particular
situation that's some advanced stuff
there you gotta think about
it is oh no he's gonna keep going for
the hell sweep watch out get the big pop
follow up for the steel pedal
my god mark man he's building something
up okay no no more rage oh it's ready
oh
wow yeah i was at the edge of my seat
that one how many hell sweeps did casey
throw out but double yeah block most of
them double moving on unfortunately
that's the end of the run for k-skate
but man i'm sure he's gained a lot of
fans here at the tekken online challenge
japan masters
double is so dirty he
whiffed that
to bait out the health block and he did
it in such brilliant fashion got to give
it up so double will be moving on and
double as we know is now going to face
off against the winner between al and
chicarin which is the next loser's
bracket matchup that's going to be
coming up so unfortunately for casey he
ties for fifth place here
and
you got to give it up to cascade you
know what he did bring in with that
kazia he tried turning up that that that
cut that the mishima
bloodline gene where you just keep okay
hell sweet hells you help sweet but
double was just ready he just knew that
all right you're gonna all cards in the
table you're gonna throw some hell
sweeps out and be ready for him and yeah
his lydia is one to really uh be
very careful if you're going up against
them
oh yeah
definitely made it work out i mean in
that last match or the last round he
blocked three health sweeps i mean he in
just in theory he should be dead right
he should be dead you know just
unfortunate for him i would have loved
to see him go for more mids but just
wasn't in the cards
mm-hmm yeah you just have to play it out
so now as you mentioned al will go up
against chicarin and this is the match
right that we say the two hard hitters
going up against each other only one
will be moving on
ow with that kunimitsu chikarin still
sticking to that geese um
do you give any sort of advantage to
anyone in this match
i i feel like i feel like chicory
chickering as a lab monster right i feel
like chicorin is always at the kind of
like at that advantage here
um but al when he met when i was on
point he is so good so for me it's
really kind of tough to call um i'm
interested to see which character i was
going to bring to the table because i
feel like aside from kuni mitsu who
we've only seen so far on stream from
him uh there's still the element of
leroy that he does very very well with
however chicorit also uses leroy and
fakamram so
that has to be weighing in on his mind
because you can we're talking about a
player that labs so much he is one of
those guys that really tries to learn
these characters the intricacies of
their characters and the options that
they have in particular match-ups so
again uh i think if if we're talking
about ao here he's either going to use
kudimitsu or he might even go to elisa
okay we haven't seen it
yeah bring about the old but gold uh
maine that he's really known for that
could throw chikaran off in a loop there
uh but yeah i do agree with you 100 that
chicken may have slight advantage
because he's a lab monster we saw it
with his match of knowledge against
gonorrhea against carrie he was really
comfy towards the the like the middle
rounds to the ending rounds how he was
able to deal with kyrie's gun reuse so
uh i was gonna be very careful in
approaching whatever character that
chicorin does choose to use
absolutely
all right we are getting ready for the
match guys if you guys are watching and
tuning in thank you for watching the
tekken online challenge you can also
follow along with the brackets if you're
on the twitch chat go ahead and type in
exclamation point bracket you'll be
updated into where we're at and it's
going to be cootie mitsu versus geese
here we go
okay yeah still sticking to these carry
they have not switched ever since we saw
them on stream
so
and back to the twilight conflict
there's something with the stage mark
man i don't know what it is but yeah it
seems like this is where we settle all
the the beefs
well are we gonna have fox meat or are
we gonna have geese meat that's the
question
so let's see what happens though
chickering always off to like a slow
start so owl is gonna have to be very
careful like he cannot rest on his
laurels if he gets some rounds in
okay oh nice pickup
good timing there with all four three
and the follow up here he has the wall
now what's the mix
so far so good on our side but we know
chicken slowly gathering data he's a
download machine he's a monster when it
comes to these type of matchups he's
probably just getting the timing but
these these lows have been landing so
far for owl
nice punisher he crouched cancelled into
the follow-up knee and now he's going to
get the full carry into the wall oh he
almost closed it out there
not looking too good for chickering two
rounds straight i was starting to
believe yeah chicken's gonna have to
come up with something or i was gonna
get no round
big launch wow just in the middle of my
sentence oh just yeah putting it all
like all on the line though
that was a huge opportunity there he
missed the combo follow-up but it
doesn't matter he gets the stab oh my
gosh stabby mcstabberson and look at
that ending it with a very convincing
perfect
uh yeah getting away with murder there
excellent three rounds straight so i
mean to move checker and um yeah does
download at the start but
oh giving him nothing there and you know
what this is still a best of three so if
al could pull that same thing off
chicken might not even have time to
download he's gonna have to act and act
quick
bro i didn't think it was gonna be that
one-sided this opening match so i'd like
to see it just here from which i know of
course he probably does have ready
but i feel like the way he was going
into the match when we talk about
chicken he's a wall right sometimes he's
just a defensive wall whether it's
throwing out safe pokes or he's playing
very conservative he could not handle
the offensive mix-ups the lows the
spacing and and the whip punishes that
al had at the ready so
again he's gonna have to change it up
otherwise we might be seeing more of the
same
yeah that's true it's just
yes you can kind of like try and give a
couple rounds just to collect that data
but i i think at some point like you're
gonna you're gonna have to like all
right
i'm getting i'm getting like cycloned
into this mix up already i need to learn
how to deal with this i need to deal
with it quick and i think he needs to
just show like put it all on the line
now when it comes to this next match
because it's really going to come down
to the wire
and owl ladies and gentlemen mind you ow
actually in the standings is tied with
neuroma they're both at 180 so i just
checked right now so they're both at 180
and al really needs more points on the
board to secure his spot here at the
tekken online challenge for the
regionals at least
well one more match will definitely help
him out in his quest for points and
we're going back to the devil's pit man
twilight conflict and devil's pit have
been the stages that we've been seeing a
lot of today
but every time we've had devil's pit and
you s it usually is the end so is owl
going to get a 2-0 here let's see
chicorin again has to make some
adjustments because right now he's just
watching and guessing wrong against a
lot of offense but this time getting a
big low parry the follow up
okay collecting some huge damage early
seconds here chickering though any good
read on that low parry but let's see if
he'll still continue owl yep
mudades gets blocked
okay
and al just knows when to go on the
defense he knows when it's too too um
too dangerous for him to press forward
nice sidestep the rebuking to the the
dagger throw
see final seconds chickering no meter to
work with just yet but does have rage
ow nice punishment oh
nice i like what i'm seeing here
i was really showing that not only is he
putting the offensive mix-ups into him
but he's also putting the brakes when he
needs to to get a punish
[Music]
yeah he's aware he knows when like not
to go tunnel vision and go all offense
and and we saw that in those final
sequence now chickering
significant life lead in early 15
seconds jumps okay
so far so good the the wall is starting
to close in with the the wall known as
chickering the defensive wall is showing
up now ow
trying to open them up able to get a few
sequences in but chicago now cashes in
the meter
oh yeah he's going to close it out nice
and easy and this is the the first you
know match round that we've seen really
go in chicago's favor hopefully he'll be
able to continue that momentum
especially now that he has some meter on
his side
no duck on the second hand the second
hit is high
ow being more calculated coming into the
approach here he knows the chicken now
um the the more you have matches him the
more he'll find ways but he was able to
snipe him out of the air there and found
the wall
oh he tried to stab him in the face not
able to get it but the downpour gets in
the crouching state
look at that sidestep he's out of there
yeah now it's chicken to the back
against the wall the 112 to carry him
across cartwheeling on him oh spends the
meter an hour just blocking all of it
markman look at the time oh my god
throws the kunai
uh-huh and he just he's out of there i
love it
i love it
look at that wow he didn't even choose
to push the action just like i'm just
gonna duck this and that was a checkmate
situation ow now potentially yeah one
more round and he can send checker in
home no uh walls in this in this matchup
now and al has been getting away with a
lot of these like just running away with
a lot of the the offense now so can he
continue in this uh fourth round
we'll see i mean he puts him into a
position where chicorin has to act now
he's at a life deficit he's at a round
deficit but this is huge this is a huge
opportunity here
yeah he had to make that one count oh
the movement again followed up oh he was
able to block it in time
oh yeah because of the positioning and
him getting hit back turn he was able to
recover a little bit faster just to get
the block on the floor forward too
big opportunity here he does have rage
he's gonna have to watch out oh he might
be dead he might be dead
wow he is dead mark man and owl moves on
setting checker in you know out of this
tournament
yeah and you know what it was incredible
more one-sided more one-sided than i
thought it would be but al with the
great performance now chickering getting
tied for fifth place as well and now
that uh lines it up to our loser semi's
final match where we know it's going to
be double versus ow so we're down to our
final four players
yeah and can i just mention that
double and our teammates so this is
going to be a team kill match
unfortunately so
but i mean it's going to bring us some
amazing matches because i'm sure they've
played each other long sets so they're
going to really put late they're going
to really pull some tricks out of their
sleeves and and just leave it all in the
line throw everything in the kitchen
sink i'm thinking of so many metaphors
but that's gonna be a great match to
watch not to mention our winners finals
that's gonna be a best of uh five now
it's gonna be genn versus nobi which
we've been building up since the start
of this stream that these are the two to
look out for the top two in the uh in
the standings currently so yep we're at
our top four
yeah and then for the loser semi-final
matches between double and ow the gilgan
battle um that's gonna be the last short
set of the tournament winner of that one
of course we'll move on to the losers
final where they're gonna face the loser
of either gen or nobi and again that
match up it could either be a rematch
between al and nobe that showed up
earlier or maybe or maybe it's a rematch
of jen and double from earlier i don't
know the possibilities are endless we
have quite a few ways to kind of slice
that but man i like what i'm seeing so
far and looking at the the characters
that we've had in place so far i mean
it's a mix of dragon off we've seen some
lydia
we've seen i don't know if we'll see law
again maybe just on my shirt yeah i
don't know we'll see law again
but uh but i think there's a there's
gonna be a lot of potential to have
lydia who knows maybe nobody's fang is
gonna come out we'll see
yeah so far it's it's just the yeah the
two lydias we've seen falcom rum as well
we have yet to see a leroy on stream
which is um
yeah something that maybe we have to
just put out there just in case like
someone's feeling like a leroy maybe gan
might bring it out or uh maybe owl might
bring it out but yeah it's still a lot i
mean the the possibilities are endless
with how this is gonna shake out
especially with uh gen versus nobi
anyone can take it but um looking at how
gen has been performing has been pretty
dominant but leave it to nobody to be
able to uh you know punch his way to
grand finals with whatever character he
chooses
yeah that's a statement you know he's
doing it on the winner's side right and
uh it was a rough tournament because
there were so many good players so many
top players so many pro gamers out of
the japan side he was really able to
come out on top um his teammates
actually did pretty well as well we saw
you he almost made it into the top 12
but he fell short to chickering earlier
but got to give it up to the masa boys
for being some of the most consistent
tekken players since tekken 7 came out
true and also shout outs to the against
teammates uh rangchu and pena they made
it they made it pretty far but you know
what they ran into some adversity
because i feel like this
online challenge like this master event
like it's a who's who a killer so for us
to be able to uh get to this top well
this top four like these guys have
really come in in the right state of
mind in the right shape because they
went through hell and high water to get
here ladies and gentlemen and they
deserve nothing but respect from
everyone that's watching so i hope you
guys are tuning in because uh this is
just like a milestone to their journey
with uh how they've been performing and
i think it just goes
it just goes up from here with how uh
these guys have been putting in the work
and uh yeah just to cap it off here with
the with the the masters event and
there's still the regionals to look
forward to i'm excited
definitely excitement on my end as well
and again between all the players that
we've seen so far today it's just been
such a treat you know obviously some of
our favorites are gone they're no longer
in the tournament but
uh looking at the matchups and the
potential matchups that we have for
these final four i gotta say i'm just
excited it's always nice to see some
some old school uh classic players that
have you know been dominated in other
games as well both gen and nobi and owl
uh
nobi ow i've seen uh playing since the
tekken six days
those guys i mean those guys have been
playing for a long time i feel like you
know it's crazy like when we talk about
some of the older games like sometimes
people will be in the chat and they'll
like kind of voice their their their
their their opinions about you know the
different games in the series they'll be
like oh tekken 4 was the best one or oh
well no one says that but oh tekken 5
was the best one was the best one and
when they say that i immediately think
that guy has to be at least 35 years old
there's no way he's never said that this
day and age with that confidence but it
just goes to show you how long
people have been playing and we talk
about things like legacy skill right
for the longest time that
these games have been played for for
more than decades now and it's nice to
see that again there's a sense of
learning matchups i think somebody
recently mentioned it i think it was rip
yesterday when he was talking about like
if you fought against lars in tekken 6
you pretty much know how to fight
against lars in tekken 7 as well which
is crazy considering that's like a
15-year gap right
or maybe is it 20 years i don't know
it's a long gap
yeah i'd like to yeah
also add into that you know the legacy
players are being uh that well the
legacy skills the legacy mindset as well
is being uh that rewarded especially if
you're if you started like in tekken 6
and carries over but also i mean the
game is at a state now where you can i i
know like here in the philippines like
there are some new up-and-coming players
that have been making a run for running
tournaments too so it's still
i say it
it's it's at that point where yeah
legacy is also very welcome as well as
newcomers so it's really a great time to
be a tekken fan especially where the
game is now and with with all these
online events all these online dojos
it's really um it's really great for you
to get that experience in competitive
tech and play and just be a fan because
you have a lot of story lines being
built not only in the japan scene but in
other regions as well and i'm sure there
are a lot of regions that are emerging
as as we mentioned at the start of the
stream
yeah and you know as we go into 2022 as
well you know in march of next year it's
going to be tekken 3's 25th anniversary
25 years
since that game has come out
that game for me was the one that really
kind of changed it all competitively
that was the first one i really started
to learn the game
uh more than you know just playing with
your friends but i tried to learn it at
a competitive level uh obviously it ages
me a bit it shows you guys how old i am
but that game and i think a lot of
people will admit it changed what tekken
was to the full 3d realm the 3d spectrum
of movement and being able to explore
the stages with your characters i
thought that was such a cool moment and
both tekken 3 and tekken tag one because
of that holds such a close
uh
so holds such a nice place in my heart
because that experience of learning how
to play games befriending people and
talking about games and how we can
improve as players it really went a long
way and obviously has kept me interested
in the series up until now
yeah honestly like tekken 3 i still get
memories of me like just watching people
at the arcade because i was so
intimidated and you got that you know
that kata of hwarang and stuff being
introduced and stuff and even tag two
has a special place in a lot of people's
heart because that's what really broke
them into the scene and it just it just
warms my heart that it's been this long
but yet the scene is still constantly
growing and uh from just being a bunch
of passionate players and now like i've
known stories of people that just
started out in arcades and now they're
being sponsored so that really warms
your heart with the hard work and
passion really paying off and and tekken
being the
being such a great game for them to be
able to show their creativity show their
passion and show their legacy skill so
yeah
it's a great time to be a tekken fan
you know when it comes to vocal people
in the community and i say this very
liberally looking at tekken 7 and how
much it really kind of exploded the
scene and it kind of changed the numbers
of viewership on top of uh amount of
people that enter tournaments it's it's
crazy when you think about it because
you know tekken tag 2
and tekken 6 at the time were some of
the bigger tekken games that we had
especially with the don and dawn of
streaming and you know things like
youtube
but when tekken 7 came out that changed
the numbers the numbers
grew blue exponentially almost overnight
and it's kept that growth level year
over year over year and who knows where
we would have been if not for the
pandemic we we ended up having one of
the most dramatic and storied
uh
esports seasons or for a game with you
know we we we have such storied history
with with regions like you know
different players in the us in europe in
korea in japan but then there's other
communities out of latin america out of
the middle east that are really starting
to
have their players more into the
spotlight
and i think it's a beautiful thing
because it really shows how global this
game really is and at the highest level
it's not about just our single region
it's about these individual players that
have really took it upon themselves to
train with certain members of their
community to be some of the best players
in the world and again it's it's so cool
to see and i can't wait till we get back
to a level where we go offline and we
get to see people like arsene ash fight
against some of the best players from
latin america the best players from the
us against the best players from korea
and japan and they battle it out and
right now this in between time where
people are kind of training and figuring
out where their place is in as far as
learning the game and getting better at
the game those guys i think the one that
are grinding it out now are going to see
the most benefit from us going back to
offline because they're going to take
all those learnings all that momentum
and everything that they've been
watching because it's not about just
playing in these events it's about
watching and seeing other players and
kind of learning from watching and
that's something that again tekken
hasn't really had the liberty of having
in the past being stuck to arcades and
you know not being having streams and
not having like youtube to kind of
reference the the way that information
travels is so much faster than it's been
in the past
yeah hard work will be paid in full
ladies and gentlemen and now where's
this toc is still a celebration of the
regions now we're going up against uh
owl versus double it's gonna be a teen
kill match you know what this is gonna
be quite exciting because i'm sure they
know each other like the back of the
hand each other's hands so let's see
this is going to be home field advantage
for kuni mitsu though
oh yeah
as we go into the match up this is what
we've been waiting to see
and right now the battle
fight
man i gotta say man let's see both of
these players teammates
going at it
who's gonna be able to i mean it's gonna
be clear because you know these guys
have been used to each other they train
with each other at times who's going to
take that imagine right now we're seeing
outplay way more aggressive than we're
used to seeing
yeah really knowing when to come in and
just reaping that rewards but
double though yeah not pulling any
punches here just uh wanting to be able
to find those openings
playing a little more conservatively but
ow nice punish there and now just trying
to control the last few seconds of this
match punishes the spring kick closes
that one out yup i was like a different
player now he's really going all out
with the offense
and that's i think the biggest change
i've noticed thus far is like al is
ready to just start banging it out right
away against double he's probably used
to fighting against this this particular
lydia in this matchup great block there
with the while standing 1-1 punish
the hopkin
yeah and also double yeah not really
showing that much hopkins but there he
was able to land it nice mid there just
for him to close it out so yeah they are
throwing everything in the kitchen sink
to each other for them to get their spot
at the losers finals
oh man al with the clutch down forward
too he's gonna push towards the wall
here
get some decent damage goes for the
mix-up afterwards
[Music]
the walk oh my god owl gets the splat
converts it oh my god head towards
though able to convert it and now just
one more chip damage for him to be able
to close this one out nice wake up there
ow gets the third round
and our situational presence of mine is
so good he knew because he was sideways
into attacking uh against lydia he went
for the one two four instead and it
netted him so much extra damage
now speaking of damage double just
showing us how what lydia is capable of
back turn mix-ups oh follow it up from
the the wheel kick
nice punish there no wall and now double
choosing yeah doesn't want to overextend
here he knows al is still a threat with
rage nice block on the low rising two to
take us to the final round
yeah you don't block that on reaction
that's one of those things that you know
from experience that he'll go for the
dash into this big sweep so obviously
the experience showing off in this
matchup here right now double with the
slight lively here let's see what he
does good punish there from owl they're
going back and forth
so far so good on the side of owl
and now double trying to work on a
comeback yeah the red tape will help him
get there
no backing away ow it does have the wall
to yeah little there but oh my god the
hot knee from owl
that was such a sick with punish that
that patience there from out it really
showed like you know what he's going to
hop kick me i'm going to let him miss
and i'm going to whip punish that and
it's great stuff good stuff from from
out there that was crazy
yeah and and speaking of like um yeah
those hop kicks right uh lydia one of
her strength is just the recovery on her
moves so the way he was able to punish
those whiffs especially at that last
sequence just shows that he's very
comfortable facing um doubles lydia and
for them to go to final
for them to go to the final round just
shows that they have they know each
other so now they have to pull off
that's the thing with team matches right
they need to they train with each other
now they got to show off the secrets
they got they got to pull something off
for them to solidify their spot losers
finals
yeah sometimes just playing outside of
the box because again you got to talk
about these guys trained together these
guys have played each other in the past
they've been watching each other play
all day on the stream
so of course you're going to have to
kind of change things up because if
you're going to throw out a move you
don't want it to whiff you don't want it
to get blocked you want to make every
move count and that's really what we've
been seeing from now from most of today
but i mean obviously it still went down
to the last round could have gone either
way
but
again these are the moments where you
play for sometimes it comes down to that
one single moment that it'll change the
momentum and go in your favor and that's
what you need that is what you need
yeah
and double let's see what he'll need um
still sticking with the lydia i'm
assuming and we'll be changing to the
precipice of fate so
again it was it was quite down to the
wire i feel like that's how this match
will end up being so
double needing to just uh yeah try and
figure out the the timing and figure out
like the ways to implore lydia's uh
known tools
all right here we go
again this is a shorter set so this is a
race to two this is the last short set
that we will see in the remainder for
our top four but again
it's coming down to these two very
skilled players and teammates going at
it to see who will be facing off in the
losers finals
okay trying to go for the those make
those stance mix-ups
and two
you can see that ao yeah just gladly
goes for the frost side floats him
couldn't get anything out of it though
and now we see the hopkin come out a
double though
uh oh
that was great and you know the range of
the hopkick he knows it so while he was
able to hit it at the max range and
still take that wall carry even though
it does go auto screw it still has
insane carry because of things like the
back three four series
yeah it does yeah just for him to be
able to just find the wall just shows
that lydia's wall game is just on the
next level tries to go for that teleport
overhead now we see double get himself
out of that wall situation
many steps just to get away from the
offense and the red tape he's going to
go for it again just went for the mid
constantly poking and you know just wait
count on double for just him to swing
big i tried to go for that hop kick once
again how able to punish
ice this time goes for the back step
afterwards
about even on life for both of these
players but double does have the round
lead let's see if i was going to take a
risk here but he gets grabbed and that
might be it no he has a sliver of life
left
oh my god
rising to the finisher of double
he didn't even have to do while rising
too but he was able to do it and just
put that exclamation point but a counter
hit this is gonna hurt because it's
gonna do a lot of damage and the wall
carry as well
uh
wow
half health already
okay
wow
that's just knowledge from just
constantly facing him three round
straight double
yeah from from an evenly matched uh
point now to just three rounds straight
yeah double has definitely made the
adjustments
yeah and you got to give it up there
because like again that momentum it's
not easy to do especially against
someone that you play with all the time
earlier you know it was a very close
match now we're tied up at 1-1
the question here is how how is al gonna
take it al played much more defensively
and much more stoic in in match number
two however in the first match he was
all about offense all about putting the
pressure on his opponent now
double started blocking a lot of key
things that would have you know
otherwise got him into trouble
so i'm thinking here at least
defensively and and and the comfort zone
that you know double is playing in it
kind of changed the the the basis of the
matchup between both of them so i think
al maybe has to start utilizing certain
other things going into the matchup and
the thing is with kunimitsu
all over all of her lows that get her
into damage situations are huge risks
they're all moves that would get her
launched or potentially killed right
and
that tells me here that
do you think we're going to see a pick
where it goes to a wallace stage that is
my question are we going to see an open
that's a good counter
that's a good choice or devil's no going
to vermillion get again a pretty big
stage but i think ao does want to
utilize that wall but you're right when
it comes to the lows of kuni mitsu she
does put herself in a really tough spot
that's why her comeback factor is pretty
tough and you know how double like
without rising too just those block
punishes are so on point so i'll we'll
have to be able to change things up and
yeah probably to kind of risk more to
gain more of the reward
anyways we're going to go into this what
is the final matchup between these two
unless they get a double ko please don't
do that to me i don't want to i don't
want to leave
i will leave i will leave the commentary
booth if they get a double ko
don't leave me mark come on yeah that
will come back tomorrow i don't know
like
teammates it's in my contract i'm not
ruling it's in my contract oh it is i'm
leaving
i should have put that in mine oh no 20
seconds already burnt and now we see
that owl is in the deficit but trying to
fight his way back in this
poking his way in this match
oh man he tried to get him preemptively
with that down forward too right now
slight life lead for double oh he's
gonna have to be careful he's trying to
jump this time counter hit okay the
follow-up and this is gonna do a ton of
damage
oh the side
picks it up
oh attacked it on with that low and ow
gets the first round so yeah stepping on
the gas a little bit with the offense
has seemed to have paid off but there's
the there's the big low and double ready
with that rising punish
you couldn't see it but i muted myself
and i said a bad word that was crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
good on the mute there oh
nice oh it's definitely turning things
up what a low parry that was insane
with his back against the wall he really
read out well there halfway through the
second round double can he stop the
momentum of ow al is playing out of his
mind now risking a lot
nice dock one more load attack it on
looks like an even match to me
go round number three let's go
back and forth between these two players
and looking at the offense things are
starting to change right now you know al
was very very aggressive now he's
starting to tighten up what is he
waiting for what is he trying to bait
out of double
we didn't get that set to counter hit oh
my god that was so close
double now backed himself up to this
corner
and now we see it try to go for the side
step four followed up oh gets the grab
instead double now has wall advantage
red tape him
he tried to catch him that would have
netted him a positive on hit what's he
gonna do here
nice whiplash oh my goodness
you know what a punished by owl
collecting as much as he can double
like just like stepping his way outside
of that wall situation no political
storm gets blocked nice block on the low
following it up with a rage drive oh the
axe kick
wow
fight
surprise surprise two rounds to one
double now on the verge of guaranteeing
himself a spot in our losers final
now needs this round to stay alive
he does cartwheels in without low once
again
risking a lot double you saw he was able
to punish that in previous sequences ow
okay he's attacking in the damage nice
walk there
but double still has that comeback
factor blocks the df2
oh he's gonna have to be careful
[Music]
exactly
what's gonna happen oh my god
double
one more but do it follow that up not
enough
ow oh my god oh
double moving on that was so close i
thought we're going to see final found i
thought mark man was going to do a walk
off like all right i'm done if it's
going to be double ko i thought mark man
was going to do that but no
double close we almost got lauren
that was that from crowdshow 403 into
the the doma washi the wheel kick he was
able to close it out that was some good
stuff but man i can't believe
that's what he went for because he bet
it all there that would have been a
launch punish and a death but again
sometimes it's all about the moves that
you don't expect coming that really net
you the positive and for him he was able
to get the win so congratulations to
double uh now moving on
mm-hmm double moving on ow you know
ending it in the fourth spot i think
he's still going to get some points and
moving him up in the leaderboards here i
think away from that uh that eighth spot
with neuromas so excellent stuff i know
it was a team kill match but yeah double
is going to be moving on uh he will be
facing the winner of the match we're
about to witness which is genn versus
nobi and you said this is gonna be the
last time we're gonna see best of threes
now from here on out it's gonna be best
of fives
oh yeah
best of fives should be exciting uh
again again and they'll be two storied
players we've been saying throughout
many iterations of tekken and you know
still playing at the highest level here
in tekken 7 uh again more often than not
has been using a mix of lydia leroy and
focus on lately and then nobi still
tried to chew with dragon off steve and
then a little bit a sprinkle of fenway
as well
yeah so that's the context we're gonna
set that uh that stage in but it is
winners finals so really important for
them to just get that win just head to
the grand finals just so that they can
like kind of relax and chill just a
little bit because you'll be facing him
against double and i'm sure that his
lydia is more than warmed up now i know
again did 2-0 uh double so double you
know again does have a target on his
back and i know double really wants to
run it back against again
and it very much has a chance to do so i
mean against again the final three
players of this tournament we got to
give it up these guys are going to be
going off with the most points and i'm
pretty sure between genn and nobi
they're pretty much a lock right into
the into the
into what we see for the finals and then
double i think it had a good amount of
points as well so these guys obviously
will be seeing them in the regional
finals i think al is probably going to
benefit the most from what we see
because he was tied for seventh on the
points leaderboard so he's obviously
gonna get a handsome amount of points
the other person that was tied with him
as you mentioned was an aroma but naroma
didn't even crack the top uh the top
nine
mm-hmm true so
yeah rest assured that yeah al is gonna
benefit from making it this far in the
tournament and note that double not too
far behind from ow he's actually in the
seventh spot with 205 and now at 180 so
really helpful that i was able to bump
up his points and just kind of uh
further the gap between the eighth and
ninth spot so uh yeah big shout outs to
al bring us that kuni mitsu gameplay
and uh yeah just incredible set with him
in double
oh yeah
and as we get ready again thanks guys
for tuning in and watching some of the
tekken online challenge with us again if
you want to follow the action that's
happening in the brackets if you are in
the twitch chat you type exclamation
point bracket for more information on
where we're at as you can see we're down
to our final three players uh as we go
into this so our next match is going to
be the winners finals we were talking
about it's gonna be an extended set
do you have any thoughts uh between
these two i know we had probably a
little bit more time to think about it
do you think it's again or do you think
it's snowbee posh what do you think
the way i see it in my head maybe genn
is gonna take it but then nobi is going
to fight his way back to grand finals
that's how i feel the storyline's going
to happen in my head but then again um
that's how i see it how about you
markman
i think it's hard to doubt again right
now again is uh a lot what a lot of
people say is the best player in japan
right now not only online but also
offline as well you know they had the
finals for topanga league not too long
ago and he was able to really dominate
the field there as well using a
multitude of characters so i gotta say
right now again is the one
that is is destined to win however when
you are that player when you are that
champion oh my goodness what are they
thinking
who are these characters i don't this is
not a lydia this isn't a [ __ ] rom but
but we see it's not a dragon with that
thing yeah wow nobody with that thing
that we've been talking about that has
been popping up as of late in dojo
events and again with the shaheen
i think this maybe because it's a longer
set they want to get a feel but let's
see how it'll pay off see those roll
dashes coming in from nobody once
i was gonna say the thing is like when
you use your main character and you know
it's arguable that ken's main character
is shaheen the one that he's been using
throughout tekken 7 there's a different
level of understanding when you're able
to play sometimes you could play
instinctively without thinking and
things happen just naturally faster
speaking of instincts that was a great
instinct to hop kick at that point
nobody now in huge trouble oh the
backswing blow lands for nobi oh nice
punish there from uh from again
nice
kind of as we go into this good blocks
there
great tempo step goes for the follow-up
guaranteed damage and look at this
turning the tables here nobody with a
huge life lead here
yeah all for a lot of those pokes come
from that kenpo like again has to be
very uh yeah just careful because nobody
gets that second round in dominant
fashion look at that look at the life
lead he had towards the end there
oh yeah he definitely made that one
count
and again it's all about the approach
and one of the tools i think the
strongest tools that we have from fenway
now is his ability to do way more damage
he got so many buffs just for his
overall damage not only on the ground
but also in combos as well because of
the usage of his moves and look at that
things are just adding up all these
grounded hits loki iron mill iron palm
yeah
oh my god yeah racking it up wow
so much damage coming from nobi he means
business and again oh blocks the
windmills
now let's see if gen can get back in
this match nice interrupt on the down
three and we have yet to see some down
back threes coming out from nobe nice
pickup there
and that's the thing too is like does he
even need to use it at this point he's
been making all the damage and all the
offensive options happen on his own
it's all been about interrupting his
opponent and kind of threading the
needle with his pokes
wow
just
yeah that's been the highlight look at
that nobi
still racking up the damage not even
from a launch nice block on the slide
but couldn't capitalize that much now
again
there's an opportunity for him gets the
slide followed up with the ff3
oh he got hit by him
he did yeah i don't know what happened
on that rage drive oh my god
usually
all right final round here match number
one again this is a race to three
hey fish hook just give him a bay no
down back threes no counter hit luckily
because when he has a back turn there's
a whole lot more mix-ups he has to deal
with oh my god hits him with a hop kick
and look at the way he's just kind of
threatening just by moving into his
space
oh nice block
oh good conversion
oh there we go down back three oh my god
he challenged and again reaping the
rewards there gets the first match but
markman that it was back and forth i'm
excited we got we got a fang in a
shaheen
yeah he got very greedy at the very end
there because you know he got the
counter hit down back three puts him
into a background state went for the
chunky back turn three
and unfortunately he got low kicked out
of it and he got into the combo that
ended up losing the match so
uh something to think about as you go
into that situation you don't want to be
put into the same situation lose out
time after time again but i have to say
from both of these players they both
really showed uh their resolve in going
into the matchup uh very strong showing
from you with fang i feel like you
should probably stick to the character
he definitely did very very well however
for uh again going back to his main main
his old main character shaheen proving
that he's still just as strong with that
character as ever
mm-hmm yeah this is uh like his when
when he first burst it back into the
scene from the hiatus it brought the leo
but he really found a lot of success
with with shaheen and now bringing it
out now
i think yeah he's conserving his
strength for probably the
the later rounds and this is technically
his main right so bring out the big guns
right away but note that he can go back
to that focus he can go back to the
lydia he's just that good with those
characters as well but with on nobi's
side though i still think yeah maybe
still stick with the fang because it did
yield him some results and uh yeah just
the constant harassment from the pokes
have been paying off and we are going to
kinder gym
kinder jim it is
it's funny too because i'm looking at
the chat and a lot of people are
they have comments about character
choice you know you got to remember
these guys aren't picking characters for
you they're picking characters to win
something that you guys can't do so keep
that in mind
okay here we go very true follow up nice
counter hit
okay
nice punish there from again
back turn oh the kenpo once again but
you couldn't get much out of it though
oh he went for the wall 72 he went for
the big punish
now moving along nicely threatening the
slide but still
hey
oh man
they're both in rage
someone's going to let it rip oh that's
that's one way to do it
yeah fall damage there down back three
excellent stuff on nobody's side
so we've seen this before right you know
nobody getting some wins but then you
know again is always a constant threat
wow
finds the wall
it's the iron fortress
now just constantly keeping him there
but oh gets the counter hit now again
able to get his back away from the wall
but we see that he does have some rage
nice
reverse kenpo he's gonna have to again
be very wary of that because the reverse
tempo can get him a lot of advantage if
he goes in wrong with the wrong move man
great blocking a great punish there
nobody looking to tie things up
yeah he was waiting for that slide nice
block on the hop kick
oh
well time kempo
that was so sick
and he gets good damage off of it here
let's see what he does
while 72 no
punish yep
wow look at them they're standing yeah
there's baiting some activities that
happen and they want to get big counter
hits big result big swings
and and uh so far nobody though
almost that rage oh
gets the shoulder one more would do it
for nobi
yo is he gonna three over
not like this oh he's looked at it too
long
headlights
yep
sometimes he just freeze like that and
again
able to act first oh down back three
counter hit
didn't get anything out of it though but
playing it a little more safe than the
previous one
oh yeah and now big combo opportunity
here he's gonna get the wall as well
let's see what gan's able to do okie
wise tries to keep him there goes for
the homing attack
oh slide again
getting so much mileage out of that
slide again
nice interrupts ken just yeah
interrupting him before again could uh
before nobody can get a big swing going
one more would do it
just the mid to check him out
this is going to be a huge round posh
because it comes down to this tied up on
rounds it's either going to be 2-0 games
wise for again or it's gonna be all tied
up we'll see what happens oh
wow
okay
nice rising uh just wake up option there
by uh nobi
no we'll be trying to fight back oh he
rolled dash away from that high
reverse campaign he's having his
opportunity
you know again doing such a great job
with the side step left he's going to
get blocked
no he got the hand oh my god he caught
him swinging
and just as you mentioned this is going
to be quite the situation for nobe now
because it's too old but all these
rounds have been going a final round
it's been quite close but again has been
able to put the pieces together
the the power of youth that clutch rage
art he's up to zero now and nobi is
probably talking to the floor he's his
head is down he is this is not a good
situation to be in not a good situation
to be in
the young man reactions right i actually
thought he blocked as well i thought
that yeah nobody was gonna get a punish
from that but what a call out from from
genn this is why we talked about it this
is why it's his main the instinct is
there even it put in tough spots right
we saw that genn uh usually gets two
rounds away from it like it's it's
nobody that gets the two rounds first
but again able to claw his way back in
those match in emphatic fashion like
that's three straight rounds technically
he just made make the adjustment and his
shaheen is looking like it's in top form
top form indeed but you know i gotta say
you know
nobody's fang is no slouch either he
really put together a brilliant set of
offense especially going into it he had
a nice lead going into match number two
but it wasn't enough he's gonna stick to
feng and and i don't know if that's the
courage and confidence that he had from
the the data that he collected in the
first two matches but he is stuck with
fenway for the entirety of this set he
has to win three straight matches if he
wants to get into the winner's side of
grand finals anyways going into the
match to see how it plays out
yeah it has gone to the final round so
he's it's it's no question that he
committed to this thing that's the iron
palm into the iron fortress
let's see though again oh my gosh these
slides have been paying so much
dividends for uh again
nice blocks man again is is so on point
when it comes to situational preparation
oh yeah goes low that time but yeah
again
i mean his offense is really on point
but something to command for him to get
there is his defense have been has been
so good stuff in all the options of uh
nobee but now it's ff3 magic carpet ride
pushing to the wall
you saw that nobody was trying to go for
the kills like just trying to go all out
but yep just tagged him with a down
three
again
still back in this match
oh kata moving twice again the punish
there on the slide he's gonna do decent
damage and also get the wall but the
side walls that still gets the full
combo
much like we've seen in previous matches
that he can take it to a round point but
will he be able to clutch it out that's
the question
yeah we've seen this story before can he
close this one out again getting that
launch though
nice adjustment yeah
a little off axis but the low parry
could change things for nobi
here we go look at the wall carry has a
good position here let's see what he
does with it however again can get out
of this pretty easily all you have to do
is slice him quite a bit
but he's not gonna let him go he's not
gonna let him out
[Music]
there we go
nobody staying alive yeah he needed
he needed to capitalize on that
situation did not want him to go
anywhere and for him to just carry him
towards that wall you just this is where
the thing is really paying off because
this could have been the same results of
the previous two matches so you know as
you mentioned he cannot drop a single
game here on out if he wants to head to
the grand finals in winner's side
oh yeah
definitely a very interesting takes you
know we've seen nobi and his approach
and it's how he kind of keeps the
pressure while he's at the wall and he's
always guessed right you know his use of
the lows to kind of really open up and
make again maybe second guess his his
offensive or his defensive capability
there uh i gotta i gotta say you gotta
give it up for no because nobody is so
good at forcing his opponent to kind of
guess at the wall
yeah and just to show also like the
confidence in his offense right you know
when he's already in the
the life deficit he'll just go all out
because he knows that all right i gotta
try my best i gotta just leave it all in
the line and you see no fear when he's
able to do that and i think nee said it
best like nobi like you know japan has
their own style of tekken but nobody can
kind of is like an exception with that
because he's so good at offense as well
and i think that's the one of the
problems he presents towards again
definitely
i will agree with you there and we get
into another matchup here
no be living to fight another day so
it's now two to one in favor of again
you know again still needs one more
match to move on to our grand finals
winner side however nobee with that
momentum and with that newfound
offensive confidence will it be enough
to kind of turn the tide here
want to see starts it off yeah he gets
blocked
still just these pokes oh wow and now in
that scramble again able to get a launch
yeah and that's quite different from
what we've seen so far from yen is he
has not yet used that tool that down
forward too to kind of interrupt the
flow of his opponent and this time it
ended up working in a brilliant way that
sidestep down 42 is something that you
really have to watch out for
mm-hmm and that's got it and nobody's
got to take notice of that don't do it
yup he is
and that's gotten nobody's attention
only be able to land it once again just
chopping away the mids goes low to close
that one out
up forward one into the one plus two he
tried to bait him for the punch
he was trying yeah nobody trying to pull
out everything in the book here
second hit nice i like what i'm seeing
here
good block
oh the walk
able to punish
but the wake up from again though
still at the center of the stage still
no real estate advantage for any of
these players just yet but wow
mark just for me to get that df2 for
nobi coming in again two rounds straight
round three i mean just like that it was
a convincing two-round straight too i
feel like dan has finally kind of sealed
off
nobody's offense here i mean what's he
gonna do and i'm glad if nobody could
prove me wrong but right now he's in a
bad position but there a clutch with
punish
let's see what he does he gets the wall
now having the likelihood that's huge
whoa bro
bro the pickups
[Laughter]
and emphatic fashion no be still in this
but yup
next round let's see if he can still
sustain this momentum
oh
he wasn't expecting
wasn't expecting it to hit his counter
hit but still it got some decent damage
out of it
look at the likely den is looking to run
away with this here but again nobody
can't count him out he was able to make
a huge comeback in that last round
oh never mind never mind again
moving on to a three to one and that
well that last round right the previous
the second to the last round we saw like
some glimpses of hope for nobi but
i don't know i think it's the violet
systems like this is really um
this is the stage where uh again really
kicks it up a notch and usually when the
round starts or like it's faint it's
it's nobody that gets the first few
rounds but on that last one uh again was
really making a statement there he was
he's he was saying like yo i i i
adjusted accordingly i'm able to snipe
you out my df2s i'm able to interrupt
you you have been blocking my slides he
put it all together there and now very
earned is his spot in the grand finals
and again uh yeah going to the grand
finals and now we see that nobody will
be facing double in the losers finals
and that one should be a doozy because
right now we've seen double he he's used
law once in in the tournament so far
that we've seen however he's been really
rocking it with lydia and lydia one of
those characters now that has proven to
be a problem especially in tournament
play she's such a good tournament
character and that's been i think the
consensus from almost everybody around
the world you know every region has kind
of agreed that she's very strong in
tournament play going into this longer
set this three out of five he's going to
be going up against nobi nobi who can
use a variety of characters we obviously
saw him use this entire set as feng way
but he also has the dragon up he also
has steve i wonder which character he's
going to use going into the matchup i
feel like it's going to be feng way just
because of certain things like the
reverse tempo step he's gonna have
things like
i guess better low tools that he could
use in conjunction with sidestep one of
the strengths of nobi that we've seen
time and again in his ability to kind of
move up close and to kind of create uh
distance between him and his opponent
whether it's laterally or or in the 3d
space right so i'm thinking here that
he's going to go with fenway for that
alone and
i don't think this is a thing that
dragon off is going to be pulled out for
but again i could be wrong it really
comes down to what your comfort is in
the matchup and i gotta say fenway is
probably really good in that matchup
against lydia
yeah that seems to be the tool that
seems to be the big sword that he would
bring out especially with how you
highlighted that nobody really
weaponizes pace he really knows when to
yeah just keep the pressure on and has
that kempo option for him to be able to
like create those openings for him and
we saw him pull that off to some success
and i do agree with you when it comes to
the lows i know dragonov's down two was
kind of well it went back to its season
one state but with how he was able to
handle that situ those situations
against again taking it to final rounds
consistently in the first two matches i
think that his fang is in tip-top shape
for him to be able to bring against
double now double though with that lydia
i mean lydia is is known as one of the
the tournament most tournament viable
character i think in japan alone like
people have like pocket lydia's here and
there now because of how well she's
doing and we saw like moments of
brilliance uh double three uh no round
browning uh uh his teammate so
i'm excited to see um what what this
matchup uh how they're gonna be able to
handle each other's characters
definitely definitely um again because
it is a longer set i feel like there's
room to play around but i mean for the
most part though we've seen people
sticking to their guns throughout the
set very rarely have we seen kind of a
change we saw that only with double so
far where he went from la to lydia
uh looking at what we're seeing into
this matchup you know nobody is also one
of those players that doesn't really
change characters unless he needs to he
has confidence in his picks and he tries
to see them out so i wonder what we're
going to see out of him as we go into
this because again this is a huge
decision going into the matchup it's all
about winning at the character select
screen
yeah but before anything else ladies and
gentlemen we will get to that match in
just a bit we'll be taking a very short
break but when we turn it's going to be
nobi versus double at the losers final
so don't go anywhere more of the tekken
online challenge 2021 when we return
uh
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we're back here at
the tekken online challenge 2021 japan
online masters we're down to the last
two losers finals and then grand finals
watch spice and the one and only mark
man giving you the commentary action how
you feeling mark man we're down to the
wire now
down to the wire and i'm feeling good
you know we have uh been treated to so
many great matches thus far and now
we've uh going back to the loser back we
just saw our winners finals now starting
off with the losers finals where we're
of course going to figure out who's
going to be today's champion and guys i
got to thank everybody for tuning in and
watching all of this action with us
today i also got to give a big thanks to
our friends over at astro for supporting
the tekken online challenge astro is the
official headset and mix-up of the
tekken online challenge 2021 and they've
been supporting tekken and the fighting
game community for the past few years so
i got to give them lots of love much
love to the astro family so posh we were
just talking about it man looking at the
players that we have left so again is
waiting in our grand finals and you know
uh that's kind of expected you know we
were talking about how he is overall the
number one player out of japan right now
so going back into what we have for the
losers final it's gonna be uh two
well-known pro players as well we have
yamasa's nobi and we also have uh
gyogun's double
so double who's most notoriously known
as a law player making the big switch
over to lydia who's a very strong choice
what many would think is probably one of
the strongest tournament characters in
the game right now any thoughts on that
particular matchup and do you think it's
going to be
lydia versus fang
i i do think it might be lydia versus
thing just because nobody's put in so
much work with that thing already and it
honestly it is it was a really close
match like i i think it wasn't like a
complete blow up even though the score
does say 3-1 if you guys just watch it
uh nobi was like constantly in in gen's
face and it was just those really big
scrambles that again was able to just uh
turn it back to his favor and
uh both these guys actually have the
well the motivation to run it back again
again did send double in the losers
bracket in winner semis and you know
again not making any friends up there in
the winter side of things so i'm pretty
sure whoever wins this wants to really
come back with a vengeance
um considering that it's gonna be a fang
versus lydia match i i do think double
is gonna stick with the lydia this has
been his strongest showing he does have
that falconrom i don't know if he's
gonna bring it out now because he's just
been so used to the the lydia already i
think changing it up even though
falconram is a very tournament viable
character i just think he's put in too
much work with the lydia already nobody
though on the other side if he always
has the option to switch it up because
that's i think that's one of the
benefits of having uh like a bunch of
characters under your belt
agreed agreed and the thing is because
it's a bit longer of a set you do have
the ability to kind of experiment at
least early on to kind of test the
waters but again it all comes down to
making sure you win those three matches
and again only one of these two players
will be able to do that whether it'll be
quick or short we'll find out
momentarily but again i'd like to think
that uh between these two players double
plays at such a fast pace you know he's
one of those players that really likes
to get in there likes to create
opportunities for his character uh
nobody i would say can do both he could
do very offensive play but he could also
play very defensively as well so it'll
be interesting to see how the pacing of
the match goes as we go into our losers
finals matchup
yeah i think with genn's winners uh
semi-finals run we saw a bit of his
defense we saw his defensive sides
against owl and when it was up against
nobi we against against again we saw how
offensive he can be so he's been showing
us like how well-rounded his game plan
is with whatever character he uses but
double on the other hand you know he had
an amazing show with against his
teammate al um
really back and forth and he had that
dominant second match with three rounds
straight so he is very capable of
pulling out all the stops with that
lydia and just um being able to use her
her great tools so we're about to head
into the match ladies and gentlemen
again it's the loser's uh finals he's
bringing out the oh my god he made the
he did switch so
we weren't ready for this we were
talking about like yeah he's not going
to pick him there's no way and he does
so this should be talking up a storm
and yeah for sure because fakaron does
have the tools just to keep thing at bay
you can just poke him out his long
reaching limbs is standing three
uh especially if things backs against
the wall like again uh so nobody's gonna
have to guess and he's gonna have to be
very careful with those charge charged
up attack
yeah one of the things we got a note too
about faker mom if you guys aren't
familiar with him he does not really
have a good sidestep probably one of the
worst side steps in the game if not the
worst however his offensive capability
and his ability to kind of mix up and
pressure the opponent is one of the best
in the game and that's really what keeps
them as a contender
yeah and again
nobody just wanting to keep him at bay
here now the pokes are coming out goes
for the low and secures that first round
and you we know that double is so good
with the while standing attacks and that
while 73 was just again proof of it
we'll go to the well once again with
opportunity presents itself but let's
see double though oh gets the crumple
and now gets the round
round yeah this character can hurt
oh yeah
oh jab there tries to keep his opponent
at bay
uh-huh guaranteed down four after that
whoa what a big board one plus two
yo big characters eat it
yeah exactly yeah
oh but yeah he could just hell sweep his
way out of it tags on a little more of
those lows pushing to the center of the
stage
double now yeah able to get himself out
of that really tough spot but nobody
again trying to press on the offense
just a little bit grab some rage oh it
didn't pull the trigger on two hit
launch
whoa
oh he's gonna do the rage art he should
be able to get this
[Music]
wow that was looking like it was going
in nobody's favor but yeah leave it to
double to pull off a comeback just like
that
great patience on double side
all right here we go two rounds to one
double right now showing that his pick
paid off he goes for the punch reversal
gets him with the kicks
and the wall here is in play
how how is nobody going to deal with
this what is he going to do okay
able to get out of that thunder i get
that jet kick
yeah sidewall though
we've seen him make comebacks before can
he do it once again didn't pull the
trigger on the forward four or four oh
able to float him he ran into he jabs
him yeah he ran into it
downstairs no he doesn't need it doesn't
need it final round here match number
one
kenpo start okay nice punish there
oh the death mills now followed up to
the wall combo tries to switch sides but
no patience on double side wakes up hell
sweeps and follows it up he's playing
like a mashima
oh he caught him with the jet
oh my god this might be it oh no the
wall wasn't there
dang
that was close yeah oof
back and forth you try to chase him down
so i got i have this spot in my mind
right you know uh obviously it was still
close it was still close but however the
problem being just the matchup with
bakamrom in general is having to battle
with him and you could tell nobody was
much more limited in how he was able to
approach the matchup because of certain
things
i have a feeling if he is going to
switch which he might
the only switch he would make is not to
dragon off but to steve because steve is
one of those characters that can kind of
help restrict what he's going up against
with [ __ ] rob so
that's that's my my thinking or my line
of thinking here but then again i'm not
one of these pro players i'm just i'm
just a guy that shades and does
commentary
we're just on the mic we're like the
professional fans we're just here to
watch the matches and get hyped but i
agree with you though if he chooses that
this matchup isn't for him even though
it did get to that final round i think
steve is the pick to go for we've seen
how his steve is able to just cancel out
those options and just just be wary of
the approach so uh that back one is
constantly a threat he knows how to get
in um and he could duck those those
those high jet kicks but seems like he's
about ready for um more of the [ __ ]
rum of double so he is still sticking it
out with fang but changing it up going
in a smaller stage dragon's nest so this
can as you would say a double-edged
sword because falconrom shines when he's
pressing you against the wall
oh yeah he has so many options and we're
not just talking about wall carry but
his ability to pressure at the wall his
guard crush moves but also certain
things like his wall rising one two able
to splat from so far away he he
definitely has great advantages in
smaller stages
still fighting at the center of the
stage but we see that nobody's still
undeterred here still trying to work his
offense but yeah double just getting the
pokes and the two hit launch
and we're gonna see the wall too
great stuff what a good first opening
round here for double again continuing
his lead
oh he's letting grip
oh
head nice
trying to go for the punch zabaki nice
movement from novi okay
back and forth they go
oh just pressuring with that jet kick
it's so scary when it's blocked still
i mean it's like pretty much like an
electric goddess the way it is on block
it's so crazy
it's so intimidating yeah just like yeah
you better watch out for this
try ducking it
for the hot kick
excellent stuff that was wild
oh the big boy combo too
[Music]
nice challenge
yeah nobody taking that third round
one more to tie things up it's so far so
good on novi's side okay
good early sequence for nobi
nice interrupt here nobody looking
really really good here in match number
two
oh the second hit you got to watch out
for it
you can't rest on double you saw he's
very capable of those comebacks oh but i
smoke bro
the adjustment the side step and pulling
out that clutch hop kick it really says
a lot for the matchup and how he studied
for it oh that was that was brutal so
now tied up one a piece where we're
going to see more of the same i i can't
see him switching from procumberam here
vagabrom has been working out for him in
in quite a good way it just it didn't
work out for him at the very end he
knows now that nobody knows the certain
holes that he can exploit in the matchup
no it's uh it's it's double's job to
adjust accordingly yeah yeah i do agree
that maybe we don't have to he doesn't
have to think about switching just yet
uh this still is a brace to three so
yeah maybe like saving up that lydia but
i think he's invested too much time and
it depends on how the next match goes if
it goes like sort of even i mean i still
think he could just rock with focaram
the whole way
but yeah um i would have to say his
[ __ ] mom is very effective
oh yeah because it's totally forcing
nobody to play outside of the box play a
different style again you know he can't
take the same liberties that he would
take normally going into a matchup and i
think that's one of the strengths when
you use a a crazy character uh like
lydia like pokemon or like leroy is you
force your opponent to play another way
and that's really i think one of the the
the biggest strengths of these
characters that maybe most people don't
highlight anyways tied up in matches
here one a piece
and i like that you mentioned that he
had to play like outside the box he had
to really create those openings those
micro steps and for him to be able to
capitalize on the openings that focus on
presents and being very careful and
making his approach
so nobi is still doing the same of the
previous round but
it just could change with a big jet kick
so let's see how double will handle this
uh this thing
oh nobody doing such a great job right
now gets the pickup
okay nobody's still on fire gets the
first round
let's see
hey he gets the screw early on double
oh not able to capitalize nice block on
the low rising three and no be
able to capitalize
and gain so much damage look at that
life already on follow it up
oh
yeah the wall messed up everything it
ruined it
mm-hmm
he just needs one more you're gonna deal
with the no are you gonna do with the
blue shoulder what are you gonna do
because that can chip them to death too
try to risk it there but yeah nobody so
far making a huge statement getting two
rounds straight
doubles gonna have to act look at that
cancel out that charged up punch goes
for the hop kick instead
yep nobody is comfortable comfortable
now in this matchup
oh
he's chopping away at the legs this is
what he does
oh what a whiff punish there no we'll be
locked and loaded
jet kick just for uh just some
compression yep
oh oh it's him out of the back turn a
nice escape there from nobi followed it
up
oh my god oh that's gonna whip buddy
wow
he's gonna take the third round double
what a call out there in that rage art
great start for nobi so far
we've seen how double again falcom rom
can hit like a truck so you have to be
very careful
tagging the legs
still not going for anything too crazy
oh we almost caught him there
look at the pressure the three plus four
yeah he's really swinging big okay
nice escape from nobi
grants double some rage away from oh
caught him coming in but no he's gonna
block that
and there's that shoulder you were
talking about mark
nobody up two to one
quite the change here
uh i gotta say nobody's doing such a
great job of kind of spacing out against
fakamram
uh
doubles in trouble double has to figure
out
what he's gonna do here in this match
whether it's gonna be changing
characters or starting to rely on
different moves to really open up his
offense i don't know what he's going to
do
yeah you just saw the the defense on
nobody's side like you know he was
trying to threaten with that uh the back
forward for the jet kick we saw that he
was trying to just open him up with
pokes but yeah you know he did tag him
just a little bit but the bigger swings
really went on nobody's favor and he was
able to yes i think it was the second
round or the third round he was able to
just get wall-to-wall combos so now as
you said double
is he's in deep waters now he's gonna
have to think about a game plan to try
and counter nobi because uh nobi has his
number as we speak so
could it you think it would be involve a
character switch or just a change of
play styles with [ __ ] rum
i think it's hard to tell i mean i feel
like ifakaram is working but it's not
working the way he wants it was working
especially well at the start of the set
but maybe it's time for a change it is
it is there we go mm-hmm
yep
getting there right in the head going
with the lydia now this is gonna be
quite tough because nobody is
running with a full head of steam double
like made the [ __ ] rum work just a
little bit
it is two to one he's gonna have to yeah
sweep nobody with this lydia
very important because he is stuck with
lydia for the duration of the set now
and he has two matches that he needs to
win
so far so good the walk and now just all
from chip that all from pokes
no b okay on ford two
oh no
nobody gets punished there and double
yep lydia so far so good
[Music]
that was a great hop kick oh man
[Music]
here we go has the wall is gonna do a
lot of damage
wow oh my yeah that was insane what a
read there
able to just get away from that
uh that option from double yeah that's
that's something double has to worry
about those kenpo steps tried to pick
him up but failed to do so now double
okay going low this time but the wake up
from nobi
clipping him
guaranteeing some wall
again huge likely night slow parry
looking to close things out one more hit
can do it
oh
i mean that's fortunate and unfortunate
at the same time
true oh
yeah he was able to capitalize a little
bit but now there will be one more round
away from heading to grand finals can he
do it double though
i want to keep him here in the losers
there we go offense coming out of double
what does he do oh
political storm he went for the punish
but not able to get it still got the
last hit
is double going to tie it up on rounds
here
can he do it
oh my god he was able to open him up
he did against the wall oh there we go
final round
double staying alive
too many jabs there got greedy with it
very very important round the most
important round of the set so far
will double be able to stay alive here
whoa
things are looking good
one more mix-up could do it
oh but man nobody finding his opening
gonna be so important here double has to
be very careful
nobody spends the rage
oh interrupt him before he could go and
nobody
wow able to three one double sending him
out of here and now it is gonna be nobi
versus again in grand finals
[Music]
they get their they get the the the
chance to fight again together but man i
gotta say looking at all the matches and
all of the stuff that we saw there that
pressure there from fenway at the very
end was just too much for double to
handle that was crazy
it was um you saw that he was he was in
in control of majority of the part there
but once he once he gave nobi that that
space you saw how well he was and and i
think tishman said it best it's hard to
especially with pro players it's so hard
to kill them if they have that just
little health left you saw how crazy how
nobi could see in 2020 like he can he
knows all the options that you're gonna
do and he's able to predict them well
and he's able to defend as well as
punish and i think that's the that's the
x factor that nobody brings to the table
even though like he does have rage he
has a life deficit he's constantly a
threat
all right and as we get ready for our
grand finals again thank you guys
everybody for tuning in it's been a
fun-filled day of course we got to see a
lot of our matches from the top 12
leading now to our final two players uh
for this tekken online challenge 2021 in
japan we are gonna be starting our
regional events in a matter of weeks
when we get to go revisit all of these
different regions see a lot of these
same players that we saw at the event so
i hope you guys are looking forward to
it and uh again
uh from this region we all know that
japan is strong but again
looking at the different style of play
do you think we're gonna see
because the players will know who's in
the top eight right
do you think we're gonna have enough
prep time for these players
to kind of change things around and
really have a battle plan going into the
regional finals
i think when it comes to the people that
are already set i think they're just
going to stick with their guns but like
let's say owl and double they still kind
of have some time to adjust but yeah
even if it is the top eight uh in
regionals like it still can go to anyone
but as as again has been so like um so
dominant i'm not sure with the japan
region but you know there's still other
regions to look forward to so we'll just
have to see because the grand finals as
you mentioned it's gonna be gen versus
nobi uh number one ranked in the
standings versus the number two ranked
in the standings and this is going to be
a run back of the previous performance
uh which was shaheen versus feng so you
know it might be a continuation might be
a part two it might be a sequel to what
we just witnessed
i mean i'd love to see it we'll see but
again it's gonna come down to this final
set now for
for nobody to want to win the tournament
he is gonna have to win two sets right
that's a tall order for anybody right
especially when it comes down to these
pro players
and you mentioned it earlier man
sometimes
killing a pro gamer
in tekken with this much life left is so
scary because they can make a comeback
at any time right they can make it
happen especially with the resources of
rage drive rage art and of course just
rage in general doing more damage
overall
i gotta say man uh again is definitely
one of the sharpest players that we have
but nobody's reads
and his experience and his way his way
to kind of transform momentum into a
winning formula is it cannot be
underestimated in this matchup even
though he's coming in from the loser's
side
yeah if anyone can do it could begin
sorry it could be nobi facing again for
him to reset it but again uh if he's
gonna pick shahi i think he might yeah
he might still stick with that shaheen
uh he's been so sharp and he's been so
on point and he's been so dominant like
two owing double three uh three to one
against nobi
i don't know what can stop him but
nobody coming from losers facing double
i'm sure that he's all prepped up and he
knows what's ahead of him and
looking back at the matches now that i
think about it it um it could have gone
either way it's just like at the last
match when genn got that third third
match victory in the fourth uh match he
like played on a different level so i
wonder if uh nobody like this time away
from facing again he was able to figure
something out against his his shaheen so
um yeah i think it might be the same of
what we're going to see it's going to be
very competitive so it's going to be
very important for you guys to tune into
this one because it's going to be a barn
burner
oh yeah looking forward to it of course
and if you guys are getting ready for it
all the action uh you guys can also
watch the vods whether it's on this
twitch channel or on our youtube channel
abandoned emco esports so make sure you
guys look it up if you want to see some
of the clips from throughout the day you
can also check our social media check
our twitter as well
at bne esports and you can see some of
the action that has been happening
throughout the entire day and for other
events as well you know we just
yesterday we had the korean event and i
i highly recommend you guys watch that
we had some epic uh battles jdcr at the
very end with armor king ended up taking
that tournament as well
so uh it was all sarcastic so so many
good players he was
and i think one of the stories there was
infested rocks dragons infested uh
really added list added people on his
list of people he upset john ding he
upset a lot of people that you would say
would make it to that top eight and it's
really important for you guys to tune in
because i mean you we had we had
quesadilla here that really showed and
gave us so much highlights of his kazia
gameplay so yeah do check out the the
vods check out the highlights and those
matches because there were some pretty
hyped sets yesterday and also from today
so
most definitely
they're just getting ready for that
match
yeah i was gonna say uh before we get
into our grand finals i want to give
another shout out to our friends over at
astro gaming uh ashford of course
official headset and mix-up of the
tekken online challenge 2021. they've
been supporting the fighting game
community and tekken for such a long
time now very happy to have them on
board with us again as we support tekken
into the future
mm-hmm yeah they're
honestly if you guys are considering
some headsets please consider astro like
they're so comfy i feel like markman's
next to me to be honest with you he's
crazy i'm actually wearing and yeah and
check out mm-hmm
i'm wearing these 840s and i have these
special you it's probably hard for you
guys to see it on stream but i have
these second online speaker tags uh i
posted a better picture of it on my on
my twitter so you guys should check that
out as well uh hopefully i can put these
back on without dropping them boom boom
the power of magnets
the power of a4
oh yeah astro guys do check them out so
yeah uh big shout outs to them big shout
out to everyone that's watching we're
finally at the grand finals i'm so
excited for this um it's gonna be quite
competitive because of we kind of saw a
teaser of it in the winner's finals
so
it might play out the same way but then
again you know what again he could also
just flip the script and just change his
character completely no
and i i mean i would be happy to see
that because you know he's able to excel
with so many different characters at a
high level so it's really nice to see
mm-hmm and that would definitely be like
how do you say someone's asking the
chats why are the commentators talking
during downtime it makes no sense let me
explain you know we're waiting for the
matches to get ready but
but but there's something that is really
hard for me to explain because it's very
difficult i think to explain common
sense to people that don't have it you
have to wait for a match to start before
you can do commentary over a match um i
wish we could just snap our fingers and
have a match start but it's not it
doesn't happen that way this tournament
is happening live and in real time so
it's actually very important and i'm
gonna give you that one this is this is
this is your free advice is when a match
starts we're gonna do commentary over it
i promise you that and if it doesn't
happen you can call us out on it however
if you're in the chat and you're
complaining about us talking
that's that's your prerogative but just
know we're gonna call it out this is a
fighting game tournament we know the bad
matchups and right now we're winning
against people that don't know because
what you don't know is what kills you
and and don't be that way just don't be
that way
there you go martin that's the markman
guarantee guys we're just waiting for
the matches so please do yeah be patient
because we want the best possible
connection you know we're also killing
some time and we are monitoring the chat
so do play nice
this is a tekken online challenge
masters in japan so here we go guys
finally grand finals time we guys are
waiting for and look at that nobody
changing things up going with the steve
fox
all right this should be fun and this is
a character from nobody we haven't seen
throughout the tournament day so far but
he's been known to use this character at
a very high level and for the longest
time throughout season three and maybe
even some of uh early in 2019 was using
steve as his tournament character
yeah so no uh
again has to be very careful because he
can gain those counter
back one counter hit back ones
he's very oppressive with this steve
but this is again we're talking about
you're so good with this
what's he doing he caught him looking
and he hit him with the hop kick a very
emphatic hop kick i mean bro he's like
one of the only hop kicks that does a
backflip when he does it
that's true
i mean one of the best looking and the
best functioning hopkins out there in
the game
let's see how nobody's going to deal
with that uh early seconds and he is
already in that life lead but you know
what yeah again always a constant threat
checking with those mids forcing him to
duck and
rest assured he has that df2 locked and
loaded
oh here we go
can the comeback happen again yeah has
some rage
oh
he was ready nice able to capitalize
tied up on rounds now
wow did you see that i didn't allow him
to continue that string nice punish from
the hop kick on nobody's side
oh 4-1 he was waiting for that magic
forward to hit and now again reaping
those rewards gets the sidewall
gets the the shaheen steel pedal or the
sand pedal
whoa
what a hop kick in again right now two
rounds to one looking to extend the lead
here
you know the momentum that he had in
that opening match when he fought
against nobi
let's see what he does here and slide
yeah it's so scary to give
again that momentum and
so far so good he has been running away
with the early seconds of this round
nobody has the work cut out for him
trying to find those openings big back
one finds its mark and also the wall
[Music]
see what he does here they're about even
on life
but the positioning is is everything
having the ability to get a launch get a
big counter hit and have the wall
can mean the mix-up between life and
death
true
and nobody's playing
nice punish he did
trying to go for a big read there early
like final seconds already side is on
nobi
now we see down three gets nullified
again does have rage he's trying to fish
for it the down three misses and now
nobi final seconds again not able to get
enough and now we're going to see a
final round fight oh yeah here we go
very very important let's see what
happens here
oh he went for the wall not
it did
luckily for nobody that could have paid
dividends and now we see again in the
back foot here
one more sequence from nobody could
steal the deal
there we go
he was able to close it out there with
that clutch up forward one and nobody
drawing first blood here showing that
the steve fox picks that definitely paid
off in this particular matchup so good
stuff
yeah and this is gonna be a long journey
for nobi right he's gonna have to pace
himself because he need
he wants the the toc uh japan masters
glory he's gonna have to reset this and
this is a good first step one match at a
time uh one round at a time a famous man
once said it doesn't matter if you win
by a mile or an inch a win is a win
that is true that issue it's all about
family as well
there we go all about family but either
way
i think
looking at this uh i i do think shaheen
is going to have a harder time going up
against the stream and i wouldn't be
surprised especially because he has some
room to kind of mess around here
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw switch
i don't think it's going to be
i don't think it's going to be
um
[ __ ] wrong and i don't think it'll be
lydia i think it might be leroy i think
it might be leroy
we were talking about how uh devastating
leroy has been and still is you know
even though there were some changes to
some of his moves he's still like from a
god he's a demigod but no still sticking
with the shaheen now again as you
mentioned he does have some room to
breathe here he knows that nobody is at
the losers maybe he wants he he has like
a game plan here going to violet systems
this is his stage so he's probably gonna
change things up in terms of pacing just
to stay away from those big counter hits
that nobi has been able to land
oh yeah down two crunches ankles nice
gets the knock down
again already with a nice light fleet
here oh he catches him with that did he
really mean to do that dang
it worked out in the end i guess all
part of the plan for him
and now let's see how nobody'll get
himself out of this situation oh my god
the hop kick
there we go and that's going to be the
first round again drawing first blood
here round two i mean it was quite
convincing too i mean the the the way
the last round ended in the in the
previous matchup it showed the dominance
of the patience of uh of nobi here
and one of the things that nobody's
really good at is pressuring with that
duck cancel you know he'll go for the
down forward one two one or he'll go for
the down forward two into into the lost
anyone and kind of fish a confirmation
out
yeah
he has been going a lot but
and luckily steve's noggin was right
there for him to be able to land that oh
my god it's the punish nobody now
like in big trouble so let's see how
again we'll try to close this out oh
rage gets nullified
one two close that one out no be in
trouble
yeah it's looking really really good for
again right now again getting
acclimating himself to the matchup and
against uh against nobody's uh style
with steve it's starting to show and
work out for him
oh look he was able to step the wall
standing too after that
brilliant sequence there but nobody okay
now
able to get himself outside that wall
trying to push for the other side of
this stage
again though very much in this match
trying to fish for his openings being
very conservative here because he
doesn't have that much life to spare
let me see that yeah nobody's trying to
trying to cover his options not not
being too open for any of gen's uh
options here
and the dash blocking just him getting
in his face and starting to block is
such a hard thing to really able to do
especially against steve
um
guaranteed follow-up and again three
rounds straight good stuff
mark what happened i just blinked and i
thought they were spacing each other out
i thought i was gonna like take another
10 more seconds but man you cannot sleep
on genn especially uh yeah when he finds
his opening he really rips into it and
he's just he's so sharp he's second to
none when it comes to those type of type
of like explosive gameplays
yeah
man all right looking into this so we're
tied up here now one match a piece
i'm trying to think here like is there a
counter to this is this something that
we're gonna see to the very end where
it's gonna go down between these two
characters and and it'll go either way
whether it's a reset or not or do you
think there's going to be another level
of strategy that's going to be coming at
least from from nobi's side because
right now it's on him whether or not he
wants to change
um i think he he still has one more room
to adjust but um
like you said he's gonna well this match
is very important right if he's gonna go
over a character switch he has to do it
now because it's gonna be harder if he
loses this match and then he has to
switch and the last one so he cannot
afford to lose with that new character
so i think he's gonna have to like the
character he picks now he's gonna have
to commit with it throughout so
we'll find out i do think that again
after that solid match um yeah
nobody's gonna have to be able to uh
adjust really like a lot uh coming into
this one
all right guys here we go tied up one a
piece here
this is grand finals
again right now with advantage of course
he is on the winner's side
nice you should get the wall here let's
see what he does
oh
yeah
okay got the blue stuff we get
guaranteed now the 4-1 lands oh my god
yeah it's these scrambles that are
getting so much uh well against reaping
so much of the reward from so
still sustains the momentum from violet
systems
yeah he's making it count
nice and again with the pressure but a
big counter in back one
that's something that we really haven't
seen too much from nobi in the match up
and look at that all that life
eradicated from his lifebar
very offensively sound start from nobi
and wow picks him up let's go
yeah able to get that conversion that
was big taking that round
all right here we go
yeah he's challenging more of those back
ones and those uh those low options okay
able to pick him up finds the wall too
yeah really made it count there great
stuff there with extended duck one
the follow-up here again look at that
using the down forward one two one
in conjunction with the flicker stance
to really keep his opponent out of there
did he press caught him with the rope he
did oh my god he did it beat this move
timing wise oh that was huge pure damage
whoa able to escape the throat oh my god
went for the dempsey but oh it's all
good on the side of novi
my god the dempsey roll the cobra weave
able to sneak out that round using the
rage drive that we don't really see
from uh from steve
yeah
and you saw how you again tried to
nullify that but yeah it was checkmate
there for nobee
oh it's raining a dragon's nest oh hop
kicks him his way out of it okay oh yeah
slippery hop kicks let's see what he
does he's back to the wall he's gonna
have to be careful gets the knock down
now it's on again dan does have the life
lead here is he gonna tie it up on
rounds one more hit could do it
wow
final round mark man here we go yeah
huge round this is a very important one
gets to counter it
oh and he's going to get the wall he
dropped it
wow
it's another counter there been so much
counter hits in this round alone
now they're really leaving it on the
line another one follow that up one more
spends the drive no b oh eats the down
four and just like that again up two to
one
not only that he needs one more match
and he will win the tournament here for
the tekken online challenge japan master
event and right now his level of
dominance i i would not put it against
him to go ahead and do that in this next
match nobody has to do something
it's uh it's dire straits at this point
yeah so far like we've witnessed the the
journey again right and so far he's been
unmatched dare i say it's second to none
with how well he's performing and we did
see some uh well we saw nobody like no
like turn on the offense a little more
but we saw how much counter hits he uh
that again was able to get out of those
situations so
it's quite tough to be in in noby's
shoes now because again i think it's
firing on all cylinders it's it's look
like it looks like he has all the
momentum let alone with shaheen a
character that he has only brought out
now against nobi
definitely
of course getting ready for what could
potentially be the final match of the
tournament but i hope you guys have been
enjoying the action so far this is the
tekken online challenge and we are about
to get ready
for our next match
oh he's going with the dragon
the commitment again okay
because of the count because nobi if he
loses one more match he is out of the
tournament he is now stuck with dragon
up for the remainder of the set he has
to win two matches
two matches with dragon up to tie things
up round one
yeah just to breathe a sigh of relief
and reset it but yeah he's going to go
with old main here
so let's see how much damage he can do
again oh gets tackled oh goes breaks his
leg
oh yeah
wow what a df2 there but again
all right this is a real test
not only for for both of these players
but for dragging off ken draganov hang
with how the momentum has been for again
so far right now it's not looking good
mm-hmm
yeah
again just dragging nobody to tough
unfamiliar territory in rough waters now
oh man slide atlanta all going up again
side though
look at the life lead
what's he gonna do
down twos
forcing some scrambles coming out again
but like he's he's not faltering he's
just standing still he's waiting for his
openings to happen less than 30 seconds
left on the clock and they're still
joking and driving for some positioning
here look at that they're still baiting
some activity like shadow boxing waiting
for something goes for the running too
nice escape on the side of again
again knows he has the likely doesn't
want to risk anything
sometimes it's about the art of fighting
without fighting and again these guys
waiting time is wasting they both have
rage
oh in a trade
tournament
how crazy was that now let's see if
again can make seal the deal with no
round brown here but look at that the
df2 lands on no beside he's fighting
back
moves away
ooh gets another launch okay
nobody with a surge of energy over the
surge of of momentum
let's see if he can sustain it
how is he gonna do it here
right now again looking really good here
making good use of that down three
oh my gosh and the punch
again slowly picking apart uh nobi here
with these lows now mids uh oh down two
able to track him down
nobody does have some rage he does have
some tools to work with here but again
just needs that one big swing can he get
it though less than 30 seconds left on
the clock eddie confirms and again
ladies and gentlemen is your tekken
online 2021 japan masters champion
what is the secret to his power i have
no idea he's so uh he seems unstoppable
he's like a world beater
that's the power of youth and
determination man that's always how it
goes and you know nobody has been a long
time player i mean even again you know
again as young as he is he's been
playing the game for a long time but i
got to give it up for both of these
players congratulations to nobee for
getting second place but the man of the
hour again
really showcasing how
how solid it is and of course the
opinion of a lot of players the best
player in japan right now
maybe maybe yeah i think all more than
just japan
yeah dare i say yeah the the best player
currently like playing tekken now
because of how unquestioning is for him
to thrive well in
this scene in japan which we say is one
of the most stacked scenes
in the world and for him i would say to
come this
to get this victory on i would say
unmatched because of he didn't really go
through that much adversity because of
how he was able to handle these matches
so yeah all eyes are on again and well
deserve victory and now he shoots
himself up in in the leaderboards like
he is solidly number one in in the
region here in japan
that's unfortunate for a lot of the
players that were battling for those
points because you know genn's gonna get
an extra 300 points which he did not
need he was already going to qualify but
it's going to secure himself a
top-seeded spot for the regional finals
that's going to be happening sometime
next year for them
good stuff but man i got to thank
everybody that has been tuning in
throughout the entire day we do have a
little bit more stuff here that's going
to be happening on the stream but posh
thank you again it's been fun doing
commentary with you you know i've been
seeing you do commentary every week on
icfc but not just that you did it for uh
for evil online as well but you also
done it for um one of the other tech and
online challenge events so it's again
great to kind of see you here uh really
talking tekken with all of us and i
gotta say if you guys aren't familiar
with with pot spikes he is one of the
best up-and-coming tech and competitors
that we have around and it's a pleasure
to have him here uh one of my my fellow
brothers from the philippines so shout
out to you posh
thank you and and uh the pleasure's all
mine to me to be sharing the mic with a
legend like you mark man i learned so
much and i'm glad to be talking tekken
with you and i'm glad to be on this big
stage and and to also be here in in
talking about uh the japan region one of
the best regions that we all look up to
it's just i think like honestly i'm just
lucky to be here so thank you to
everyone that have me here thank you
mark men for sharing the mic with me and
thank you to everyone in chat for being
so nice and you know what i know the
matches took a little bit long but we
got there and yeah we did get to the
grand finals so
uh honestly the day was was uh full of
good ass second neither you're saying
i have a question for you actually i
just noticed uh your hat your hat has a
donut on it
right i think you did did you predict
can you predict or will it into
existence that donuts again would win
the tournament
yeah i'm glad you brought that up i feel
like that connection was there
boom it was there yeah you saw you saw
through the the easter egg he did that's
that was supposed to be the post-credits
scene but yeah i this was my way of kind
of supporting i actually um i was really
looking forward to seeing uh hakaio
that's why i got the king shirt but you
know in my mind i was like it's again i
think it's again
or one of the donuts boys at least so i
put my bet on wearing the the lost shirt
but but he only used law once
but it did come out i feel like that's a
prediction on its own so yeah
mystic mark like looking at his crystal
ball he will predict that i would have
never thought the law would come out to
be honest
yeah i mean especially with the strong
characters like he's been using used
focus lydia but again i guess we should
kind of talk about um how the tournament
placings were and and for the actual
tournament itself i'm going to bring up
the standing so we can talk to you guys
about uh the top eight so as you guys
know the winner of the tournament was
donuts usg again he got first place nobi
ended up getting second place double
getting third al getting fourth uh and
then casey also getting tied for fifth
along with chicorin and then in seventh
we have kurukuzen and kade
so that is our top eight for today i
hope you guys were able to enjoy all
these second matches and again you guys
can watch all these matches through the
archive here on twitch or you could go
over to the bandai namco esports channel
on youtube and watch the archives as
well
yeah so it does shake things up i
actually want to see the updated
standings but for the first two like jen
and nobi they're in a great spot
chikaran as well i would say does go
with a little bit of points and here we
have it already here are the standings
again and no be still locked in at first
and second and now look at the double
able to jump up 355 points and tied with
chickering at fourth place but what
about fifth place mark
well looking at fifth place i'll right
now is able to kind of jump even further
i mean i mean sorry i'm like kind of
staggered at looking at gen's point
total 670 i think that's the most it's a
lot of scene from any region from any
region so far i think that's probably
the most i've seen but of course uh rank
chu is also in the top eight and you
know this is i would say it's kind of
pretty much final right because there
are no more dojo events that are gonna
be happening between now and started the
regional events so looking at overall
the top eight in japan we still have
rongchu pina and we have naroma that is
quite the stacked deck for what is going
to be or what could be our regional
event finals
yeah just
670. that's a lot of points and
considering he jumped who was 370 at the
start he gained 300 points uh yeah
again is a madman for him to be able to
compete at this high level i'm i'm
excited to see how the regionals will
play out and there will be some time so
i'm excited to see if anybody's going to
come up with a solution
for genn because it seems like he's got
everyone's number he's he's faced his
fellow teammates and rang chu and pinya
he's faced nobee from time time he's
paced double but yet he's still very
unmatched with how well he approaches
each match and he brought up the shakin
i actually thought he was going to bring
lydia uh to the finals here but you're
showing us that he still can rock that
shaheen
oh yeah we are going to be showing you
guys uh a few slides and a few a bit
more information for the regional finals
that will be coming up of course uh for
japan in particular if you guys are
looking at that one this one that one
happens uh december the 26th but of
course every region is going to be shown
you guys can see it on the screen top
eight of each of the region's
leaderboards will be invited to
participate in the regional finals and
you can see the dates so all of the
different regions that we've been able
to hit south africa the middle east
south america west africa central
america the philippines and east asia
south asia southeast asia oceania
west europe east europe japan korea and
we're going to be ending things off with
north america early next year
now aside from that going into the rules
you guys can actually see it's a bit
unique this time around the first and
second ranked player for each of one of
these regions will be assigned to two
separate pools so there's going to be a
pool a and pool b the first ranked
player will be able to select one of the
qualifying players to be put into the
second pool of red players and vice
versa and tara they're until they're
full so you guys can kind of see it will
go back and forth between those ranked
players to kind of pick who goes into
the different pools and they're each
going to play wow
round robin series in there and of
course once we do the round robin that
brings us to our next stage where the
first and second ranked player from each
of the round robin series will advance
into the final bracket and the first
place person in each round robin will
start on the winners then the second
place person will start in the losers
bracket so
that will be a final playoff of the
final four in brackets series and every
match in the final bracket will be a
best of five for double elimination
crazy huh wow
yeah i mean the the whole point of like
the the mind games begin right away so
it's really important to get those first
and second place standing so looking at
it now again and nobody have a lot of
thinking to do which which they want to
be which uh players they want in their
pool and yeah best of fives are a
completely different story now because
you do have that room to explore so i'm
really excited for those regional finals
oh yeah and one more reminder like going
into it uh the region's selection will
be recorded and shared through social
media so stay tuned for more information
of course you guys can check out
tekkenworldtour.com and then of course
our social media channels on youtube we
have b esports on facebook also be any
esports and of course on twitter we have
uh the tekken account and of course the
bne esports account as well so i hope
you guys enjoyed that actually we have a
slide for the price but i don't know if
the team could bring it up but we did
want to kind of talk about the price
pool that's going to be happening for
the event this is the stuff i just
talked about but the prizes will be
awarded and set forth based on the the
listing that you guys see below the
price payments will be made in u.s
dollars and right now it's six thousand
dollars per regional final so of course
first place getting wow
50 of that so big three thousand dollars
for first place and it goes down even
smaller up to the rest of the top eight
dang
again guys yeah for any more rules or
details go to
www.tekkenworldtour.com for more
information or as markman said just
follow the socials to stay up to date
with everything related to the tekken
online challenge 2021.
and i think that's going to do it for
everybody here that has been watching
throughout the entire day it's been a
fun-filled tekken weekend yesterday we
had the korean event watch that vod and
if you missed most of the day make sure
you watch the vod as well posh is there
anything that you want to say to the
tekken community before we enter the
night
big shout outs to everyone that tuned in
thank you guys so much for uh like
watching and also big shout outs to all
the players that were able to you know
give us some good ass tech and a watch
today every big shout out to the people
in the back i know the time difference
might be crazy but you guys still keep
us up to date and you know we have
when we're behind the scenes we just
joke around so yeah i think i'm really
just thankful to be here i'm very lucky
and i can't wait to see more good ass
tekken uh when it comes to the regional
matches so let's go
all right and posh i hope you enjoy the
rest of your day i know it's uh probably
what early evening for you right now
evening early late afternoon
all right so i hope you enjoy the rest
of the day for me it's four in the
morning so i'm gonna try to get some
sleep or play more video games but
either way thank you guys for tuning in
and look forward to those regional
events of course as we as we reminded
you tekkenworldtour.com for all the
latest updates or check one of our
social channels out but everyone in the
chat thanks for putting up with us for
the past few hours we will see you guys
next time keep playing second and take
care bye everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you